committee members present we'll go ahead
and open the meeting
on the house bill 220 study committee to
study medical interventions and
immunizations i actually all arise as we
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god
there we go
all right
so we can open up the meeting this is a
public public input session i'm hoping
we'll have good conversation good
dialogue questions and answers as we go
on um the one thing i will say there are
three important words civility respect
and conciseness
um i'd ask you to be uh civil in your
speaking speak to the policies and not
the people involved in the policies
speak to the speak be respectful of all
the different opinions in the room and
no shouting anybody down let them have
their say just like you want your say
and lastly be concise everyone's time is
important let's not repeat information
over and over again if we don't have to
i'm in it we're interested the
community's interested in hearing your
your
input on this we may ask you some
questions if you're willing to take
questions and you may ask a question on
the committee if you'd like and we'll
see if anybody here wants to answer it
there'll be some things we may or may
not be able to answer but if you have a
question we'll try to answer it
that being said everybody understand how
we're going to go move ahead
great so i'll call our first public
and i'd like it if we can try to keep
all the conversation down around five
minute mark if we can if it goes a
little longer that's fine
but let's again be respectful everyone's
time and and
letting everybody speak
go ahead andrew just give your name and
your city a living thank you mr chairman
andrew menews i'm a
resident of dairy new hampshire
i'm also the chairman of rebuild new
hampshire reopen new hampshire
but today i am actually here
representing first fruits ministries i'm
the pastor of that
organization and i'd like to speak to
the bible relative to vaccination
um
so
our bodies belong to god this is
supported by scripture
it says in psalm 103 know that the lord
is god it is he who made us and we are
his we are his people the sheep of his
pasture
ezekiel 18 4 behold all souls are mine
the soul of the father as well as the
soul of the son is mine and the soul of
the sin uh the soul who sins shall die
and then 1 corinthians 6 19-20
or do you not know that your body is the
temple of the holy spirit who is in you
whom you have from god and and you are
not your own for you were bought at a
price therefore glorify god in your body
and in your spirit which are gods
and then one corinthians 3 16-17
explains the punishment for defiling
the body do you not know that you are
the temple of god and that the spirit of
god dwells in you if anyone defiles the
temple of god god will destroy him for
the temple of god is holy which temple
you are
god thus commands us to guard our bodies
against defilement knowingly allowing
our bodies to be defiled brings complete
eternal destruction
leviticus 11 17 14 deuteronomy 14 acts
15 19 through 21 corinthians 10 18-22
define what defiles the temple body when
it is consumed or injected into the body
jeremiah 1 5 psalm 139 13-16 isaiah 44
24 to find the sanctity of human life
from conception
in exodus 21 22-25 among other verses
identify punishment for harming a child
in the womb
the covet 19 vaccine in particular
includes known substances that are
potentially harmful unclean or defiled
but we don't know all of the cova 19
vaccines proprietary ingredients we do
know that these vaccines include lipid
nanoparticles that can pass through the
blood-brain barrier
and polyethylene glycol unknown allergen
we also know that all available vaccines
were developed and or tested using
aborted fetal tissue
any vaccine that is designed developed
tested and or produced using aborted
fetal cell lines defiles the temple of
god and is biblically forbidden
and that goes for all vaccines not just
the cove at 19 vaccine
the johnson johnson vaccine advertises
use of aborted fetal tissues on its
website the pfizer bioentech and moderna
vaccines which use manmade mrna
technology inject synthetic like virus
objects that operate by deceiving our
god-given immune system
via synthetic lipid nanoparticles that
block the body's natural defenses
just in its mechanics this
technologically this technology
fundamentally rebels against god by
first deceiving and then hijacking god's
creation
in favor of man's creation thereby
defiling god's creation through idolatry
and then we look at romans 13
which outlines government authority woe
to those who call evil good and good
evil comes to mind in isaiah 5 20. so
the passage in romans 13 says that
government is under god's minister to do
good which means that government's
authority is under god's authority only
when it does good
what if instead however the government
calls evil good and good evil what if it
becomes an avenger to execute wrath on
those who practice good instead of on
those who practice evil i think i've
established fully
that to do good means to obey the
commandments of god
and to protect the sanctity of our
bodies
so thus not injecting our bodies with
something that defiles it amounts to
good and if the government is being used
to force people to violate that precept
the government is now rewarding evil and
punishing good
since our bodies belong to god and what
we put in them as directed by his law
government does not have the purview or
authority to force individuals to inject
themselves with a substance of any kind
for any reason whether or not the
vaccines have unclean substances is
besides the point but it certainly helps
solidify an argument to obey god rather
than man
now federal law title vii of the civil
rights act of 1964 prohibits
discrimination and hiring promotion
discharge pay fringe benefits job
training classification referral and
other aspects of employment
based on race color religion
sex or natural origin national urgent
so
the message today is that i'm asking you
folks in the legislature
to stand up and help defend the law
by rewarding good
and
what that means
is protecting the law under title vii
protecting people's religious right to
object to vaccination of any kind
um at any point in their life whether
they're an infant all the way to uh them
being infirm in a uh you know an
assisted living facility
everyone who is a citizen of this state
deserves to have their life protected
and the sanctity of their body protected
and it is the government's job to do
that thank you
thank you are you willing to take
questions
sure
anybody from the committee have a
question for andrew
seeing none thank you side andrew thank
you
so i apologize one of the things i
usually do when i start this is to um
read off we have 32 bills that have been
filed in the state house um this session
uh relative to either four on on four
topics covid masking mandates
vaccination
so i meant to run through a list so
everyone understands what the bills are
that are currently pending
so you have an idea of what what's
happening already in the state house
rather than these topics so bear with me
i'm just going to read the title of each
relative to requiring covet 19
vaccinations for school attendance
requiring new hampshire attorney general
to empower and panel a coveted 19 grand
jury to investigate the events related
to the covet 19 pandemic
relative to state grants for researching
the effects on the human body of covid
19 vaccines
requiring post-secondary institutions to
accept religious or medical exemptions
from vaccine requirements
requiring an audit of the new hampshire
vaccine association
making the state vaccine registry an
opt-in program
relative to the exemptions from vaccine
mandates relative to the exemption from
school vaccine mandates relative to
students attending public schools that
mandate the wearing of face masks
without an emergency order in place
limiting the authority of the department
of health and human services to mandate
vaccinations relative to the quarantine
costs
relative the state enforcement of
federal vaccine mandates
relative to the
medical mandates adopted by employers
relative to employee protections from
coven 19 in the workplace prohibiting
the state and local governments from
adopting certain mandates in response to
kova 19 and to prohibit employers and
places of public accommodations from
discriminating on the basis of
vaccination status
relative to the procedure for withdrawal
from the vaccine registry
requiring the department of health and
human services to maintain certain recon
records relative to vaccine registry
expanding the prohibition against
discrimination based on employee
election not to participate in the state
vaccine registry
for him the department of health and
human services are requiring vaccine
passports for services
prohibiting higher education
institutions receiving state funds from
requiring face mass and covenanting
vaccinations vaccinations for attendance
proclaiming the first monday of march as
covenant 19 victims and survivors day
relative to the limited liability for
for personal injury resulting from or
related to the exposure of covert 19
relative to the unemployment benefits
for employees terminated for refusal to
comply with a vaccine mandate
relative to the unenforceability of
non-compete
agreements upon termination of an
employee for non-compliance with the
vaccine mandate
relative to a vaccine mandates for
government contractors
relative to
financial responsibility for employers
mandating covid19 testing for employees
for him a school district from mandate
and covenanting vaccination for school
attendance prohibiting certain employers
from requiring coping 19 vaccinations as
a condition of employment
relative to the eligibility of workers
compensation for adverse reactions to a
mandatory covid19 vaccination
requiring full fda
approval of vaccines
relative to cova 19 health and safety
policies at new hampshire performing
arts venues
relative to school district policies on
facial masks of students in schools
and lastly requiring independent audit
and needs assessment regarding covert 19
preparedness
at long-term care facilities nursing
homes and a new hampshire veterans home
and making an appropriation thereof
so those are the bills that are
currently before the legislature that
we'll be acting on in this session
so i just want to give everybody kind of
a basis of information and know where we
good morning members of the committee my
name is dr david strang i'm a resident
of gilmanton
i'm also a 1986 graduate of dartmouth
medical school and have 32 years of
practice experience
in the specialty of emergency medicine
i rise today to speak to you about the
evils of mandates particularly when it
comes to those involving these covid
vaccines
what i'm about to explain to you now
does not require a medical degree like
mine to understand only common sense and
an open mind
we all know that once per year the
influenza virus mutates necessitating a
new flu shot before each and every
winter
the covet 19 virus has mutated
approximately 12 times in two years or
six times faster than the flu
yet we are still being urged to get the
same coveted shot that was based on the
original variant of the virus that began
circulating almost two years ago
does that make sense to you
of course it doesn't
remember when the vaccines first came
out and we were promised that once
vaccinated you could take your mask off
because you wouldn't be able to get the
virus
when the vaccinated be
began getting sick that promise was
retracted but replaced with a new one
that vaccination would prevent serious
illness and death
this too was proven to be a lie as in
the month of september in vermont
76 of all cova deaths were amongst the
fully vaccinated nearly identical to
vermont's vaccination rate of 79
if vermont's data does not convince you
let's look at that from the united
kingdom again in the month of september
75 of all deaths there were amongst the
fully vaccinated
this does not come from some
anti-vaccination group but the uk's own
national health service
and finally let's look at waterford
ireland where 99 percent of citizens 18
and older are fully vaccinated yet their
covet case rate is three times that of
the entire country of ireland if the
vaccines do not protect against
contracting the virus and do not prevent
death from the virus
what good are they
and now there is an unjustified pressure
to vaccinate children
children are the one segment of the
population best equipped to handle this
illness
they do not die from it like adults in
fact in new hampshire a state with
almost 1.4 million residents
there have been no
covet deaths amongst children
in the country of sweden where there was
no lockdown and schools were kept open
there have been no covet deaths amongst
children
in fact in all of the nordic countries
combined where there are almost 1.8
million school-aged children would you
like the hazard to guess as to how many
childhood cova deaths there have been
that's right zero
the risk of death from covet amongst
children calculated by the israelis is
one in two million
that's 0.00005
[Music]
percent
the risk in children of vaccine-induced
myocarditis which is inflammation of the
heart muscle pericarditis or
inflammation of the sac surrounding the
heart or myopericarditis a combination
of the two is hundreds of times higher
and these vaccine side effects do kill
children
dr moulton martin caldorf professor
professor of medicine at harvard
university
biostatistician at brigham and women's
hospital and on several advisory
committees for both the cdc and the fda
who believes in the benefits of
vaccination as do i
does not
recommend the vaccination of children
with these substances stating that the
risks far outweigh the questionable
benefits
dr robert malone the man who invented
the messenger rna technology behind all
of these vaccines says quote
there is absolutely no scientific or
medical judgment for vaccinating
children end quote with these substances
to contemplate mandating the nationwide
use of these faulty interventions is
just not supported by the science
furthermore mandates violate one of the
foundational blocks of the practice of
medicine that of advice and consent
as physicians we advise our patients and
they have the right to consent or not
consent
if we mandate in defiance of individual
choice and freedom then we have
destroyed the doctor-patient
relationship
the economic coercion contemplated by
concord hospital dartmouth hitchcock
medical center and others is despicable
and a violation of medical ethics
in closing i would like to stress to all
of you that we do not need religious
exemptions
we do not need medical exemptions
we already have an exemption
that is we are americans we have the
god-given right to say no
thank you dr strang
i'll be happy to answer any questions
and i'll be happy to give you a copy of
my written testimony i appreciate the
written testimony questions for the
doctor
great thank you any other questions for
the doctor
dr strang i have one for you so don't go
no i don't get away sorry so we were
having a discussion the other day with
both the attorney general's office dhhs
and the medical society and the hospital
society new hampshire hospital
association around informed consent
and the attorney general's office was
pretty clear that informed consent must
be free and voluntary
and the idea around informed consent is
a doctor notifies the patient of of the
outcomes of of the pros and cons so to
speak of a given medical procedure and
then allows the patient to make that
decision
given given the mandate
does that pose a problem for doctors and
ethics if you have if you have people
coming in to get the vaccine
who are being
told by their employer
you get the vaccine or you get fired so
threatening their the ability to put a
roof over their head food on their table
for their children
and then that that employee goes to a
provider to get the vaccine and says i
gotta get this because i'm mandated by
my employer
is that would you consider that a free
and voluntary consent and would you
would is there an ethical problem with
the doctor giving a shot under those
circumstances
that is not free and voluntary consent
you are providing economic coercion
by an employer whether that's a medical
center like dartmouth or concord or
a a an entity like the u.s government
which is trying to originally mandate
companies that were
had employees of 100 or more and now
it's going to look at any company that
does business with with the federal
government
since i'm a physician and i would
potentially build medicare i'm there for
a contractor
so
am i going to be forced to get
vaccinated or vaccinate staff in an
office that i work at against our will
that's what the federal government is
attempting to do this is economic
coercion and
in my opinion it it violates
what i consider to be as i testified
earlier the foundational blocks of of
medicine which is advice and consent if
you can't convince a patient of the
benefit of an intervention of its own
merits
then you've lost that argument
and if you suddenly say i don't care
what your choice is we're going to
mandate you
how do you have any trust in the
doctor-patient relationship anymore
you've destroyed it thank you doctor
any further questions for dr strang
there being them thank you again doctor
if you could turn that into erica right
next up is
thank you for the opportunity to testify
you just speak up and speak in the
microphone so everybody can hear you
sure thank you for the opportunity to
testify on behalf of in front of the
commission
my name is marcy doyle and i'm a
registered nurse from bedford new
hampshire i work at the university of
new hampshire as a nursing professor and
researcher who studies delivery of
health care to the residents of new
hampshire
i'm a new i am also the new hampshire
association chair of the commission on
government affairs
profession u.s health care profession
delivering health care to our most
vulnerable
populations we count on them to answer
our call bells
when we are hospitalized
to provide us with hygiene in long-term
care settings and to educate us on
medications chronic disease prevention
strategies and vaccinations
they are the most trusted profession in
the united states
for well over a year
we were at the forefront of the coven 19
pandemic with no vaccine immunity and
few treatment options
most nurses have been left with the
trauma of watching countless patients
die here in new hampshire and across the
country
unnecessarily
they have left their families shift
after shift
to save as many people as possible we're
tired
most nurses here in new hampshire and
throughout the united states are
vaccinated
90 percent about
four kova 19 over 85 percent of nurses
are willing to get the booster shot
87 percent of nurses say they stay up to
date on trusted and reliable information
in our referring patients to those
sources such as the centers for disease
control and prevention to learn more
about coven 19.
nurses are looking beyond the pandemic
they want to lead in workforce safety
we always have
in supporting the development policies
that prioritize the patient's care
starting with having an immunized
workforce
which is not new to us
wearing masks and hand washing i thank
you
are you willing to take questions
yeah
does anybody on the committee have a
i'll ask one um so again we're nice to
have a medical provider in the of in
room
answer some questions so again around
the idea of a mandate and and the
decision around mandates for any medical
intervention whether it be vaccination
or otherwise
the question i have is that ultimately
is it the patient's choice or should it
in terms of the patient it's the
patient's choice to get vaccinated but
as healthcare professionals we reside in
a high risk setting and
we are providing care
and by the patient bill of rights you
know we are providing that care and they
oftentimes don't know if we're
vaccinated or not they could be
unconscious or whatnot and we're really
looking towards decreasing the spread of
all
diseases
so it is the patient's choice of course
thank you anybody else
thank you okay i figured out the
microphone um thank you very much for
your testimony um i'm questioning the 90
of nurses that are vaccinated sure right
now we have lots of availability so if
the remaining 10 choose not to get
vaccinated and then leave the healthcare
workforce what impact will that have on
their nursing colleagues and patient
care
sure that's always a concern right but
also the cost of delivering care in an
environment which we're not embracing
um
reduction
processes is a real concern
so one of the things that's happening is
slowly over time people have decided to
get vaccinated we are concerned about
workforce changes but we're we're there
for the patient we need to be there and
and be safe and not giving the patient
an infectious disease or our colleagues
so we need to work with those that do
not want to be vaccinated
there in the ets there are three i'm not
sure if you've read it but in the osha
there are three
components in which would would allow
for folks not to have the vaccination
and that was released last week
religious
disability
medical and so you know as always i
think
steve from new hampshire hospital
association testified last week we
always want to work with our workforce
we always want to support people
that's what this is all about
you know at the new hampshire nurses
association it's a big deal we we want
to work and we want to understand what
those concerns are and we want to trust
the science and we want to question that
science you asked a lot of great
questions last week
regarding studies and evidence we want
you know a and b
evidence
but we also need to know we're in a real
time
fast
pace changing pandemic and i recently
ran a learning collaborative with my
colleagues for long-term care and we
could track seven patients in one
organization who actually passed because
someone came in with covid you know so
there's some real challenges we need to
think about a workforce being one but
really patience patients understanding
hey it's a safe place and that's not
infecting our colleagues and not driving
up health care costs which we're very
concerned about
um i have a follow-up if i may follow up
does the covid vaccine prevent
transmission of covid
so it reduces transmission right
it greatly reduces
it greatly reduces transmission of the
virus right and it reduces
the morbidity or mortality associated
with it and studies have shown that and
that's why we've seen a reduction
it also is an rna virus which will
mutate
and that means that we
are really we're behind the eight ball
slightly in terms of getting folks
vaccinated the more you let an rna virus
replicate the more mutations it will
have and it will optimize
to potentially make a more dangerous
variant so that's really a concern
thank you and then one last follow-up is
there any respect for natural immunity
with the new hampshire nursing
association you know we haven't
discussed the natural immunity piece i
think that's a really good question and
a really um you know i think you look
similar to my age we had chickenpox
right and so i think that's a really
good question and we need to continue to
work on that and have these discussions
so we thank you
good jeff
thank you for taking my question uh we
addressed the issue of the vaccine
mandate uh having an impact on the
nursing workforce yes
do you have any data
about the impact of not having
the vaccine
on the workforce in other words we think
of it as
having the vaccine mandated
decreases the workforce
equally do you have any data
about
not having the vaccine
losing workforce
yeah sure if you don't have um if you're
not vaccinating say we were to have an
outbreak here in concord or at one of
the um you know we have 26 hospitals
or hospital type settings right so if
you
can think about having a majority of
people unvaccinated
then you could potentially pull down one
of those hospitals in an inability to
access care so
you know we had to prioritize during the
early stages of the pandemic who we
would see
and so that was a result of you know
being overwhelmed so in the seven people
that i um mentioned that passed that's
also a result and a long-term care
facility in in
the new england region that's also a
um
challenge right seven people passed
because they got covered because some
one brought it in and that was when
lockdown was a hundred percent and it
was a healthcare worker who brought it
in so
um
anything else is that ng a question any
next up is harley merrill
harley
look at her side maybe she stepped
outside
sorry i
thank you for allowing me to speak today
i'd like to talk to you about the
vaccine mandates that affected nurses
and health care workers in our state and
around the country
i was a critical care nurse for 30 years
prior to contracting a chronic illness
which took me out of the workforce and
robbed me of my career
we say in nursing once a nurse always a
nurse it is who you are
nurses give all they have they work 24
hours a day
they work short-handed they stay later
than their shift if needed they
sacrifice breaks for the sake of their
patients they advocate
fiercely for them when necessary nurses
go to work sick tired in snowstorms and
when the rest of the world is enjoying
their holidays
when the coven 19 virus broke nurses
were there doing their jobs
taking the risks on themselves and their
families because people were sick and
needed help
when the rest of america was tucked away
in their homes nurses were running into
the burning building
many times without proper protection
hospitals told nurses to wear their
single-use masks and gowns until they
fell apart
there were no cries for the safety of
healthcare workers
but still they went to work and did what
they knew what was right
they were called heroes
now after much of the population has
gotten what they were told was a vaccine
to protect them from the virus
we forget that those that these heroes
are people with rights of their own
nurses who are not comfortable with this
supposed vaccine are being told to take
the jab or hit the road
this is a funny way to say thank you to
those who risk their own lives and the
lives of the ones they love
reasonable people can disagree about the
safety of this purported vaccine
are choosing not to take it
these are people that understand
medicine and the rigorous testing that
vaccines and medications go through to
get approval
these are people that understand that
these substances have limited testing
for a limited amount of time there is no
data on the long term effects
this science is experimental and has
been fast tracked to the public
one detail that no one wants to point
out is that the fda still has not
approved any of these substances
the big lie that pfizer
is approved is not true
it is the german company viantech's
product
comernati
that was approved by the fda
carmenetti is not available in the
united states
pfizer was given an extension of the eua
emergency use authorization
not fda approval
this can be verified by looking on the
fda website
this makes pfizer the pfizer drug an
experimental substance there are no
approved and safe vaccines for covid19
under the nuremberg code it is illegal
to mandate an experimental substance to
anyone
these mandates are illegal
there have been studies in italy that
show natural immunity to be more
effective and last longer than any of
these supposed vaccines
people who have had covid or were
exposed to it have already acquired
natural immunity
basic fundamentals of immunology have
been thrown out the window to ensure
every living thing on this planet gets
the jab
why
who stands to benefit from this
why does the vaccinated person need to
be protected from the unvaccinated
that doesn't even make sense
why are people who refuse the job being
forced to undergo frequent testing
with a faulty test that expressed
exposes them to a swab dipped in a
carcinogenic
it is well documented that covid
vaccinated people are able to contract
and spread the virus yet unvaccinated
are being threatened with their
livelihoods
is now a pandemic of the unvaccinated
well how do we know that even before the
jab people had varying degrees of
symptoms and many were asymptomatic
the jab is reported to decrease the
severity of symptoms so it's very likely
there are people walking around with
covid not showing symptoms who got the
jab
the constitution guarantees all people
the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
taking a person's job who will not
consent to an experimental injection is
a violation of the constitution
making it illegal
sovereignty over one's own body is of
the highest priority
the taking of a person's ability to
provide shelter and care for themselves
and their family is not only illegal but
immoral belong beyond belief
the federal government has no right to
circumvent the constitution by
pressuring private companies to mandate
their employees into taking
any medication much less an experimental
one
they are causing private companies to do
their dirty work because they know it's
illegal for them to mandate the people
directly
i understand that our governor doesn't
want to interfere with private business
or private companies
but where does that leave us
the people of this state
do we just sit back and let evil prevail
or do we fight back
you have been given the responsibility
by the people of new hampshire to look
after their interests you hold many of
our futures in your hands
we need the legislature to stand up for
people
we need your help
i know the desire is there by the fact
that i'm here right now
please consider the the following when
you debate when you deliberate this
topic
number one
bring a lawsuit to president biden and
his administration to stop this
insanity number two allow every person
who applies for an exemption to be
approved
number three
pass a law that prohibits the
discrimination of workers based on
vaccine status
number four consider testing for
antibodies before asking someone to
consent to an experimental substance
number five initiate a more robust
treatment protocol for patients with
covid19
allow for monoclonal antibodies and
ivermectin
to be administered when requested and
appropriate people are being denied this
treatment
number six
stop the efforts to compile a registry
of vaccinated and unvaccinated
this is a dangerous step in the privacy
of individuals and could be used as a
tool
to search out the unvaccinated in the
future a person's medical information is
between them and their doctor the state
has no right to it
these are just some of the ideas i'm
sure others have more
this progression to
cannot go on we are dangerously close to
losing our constitutional republic with
the way this issue is being addressed by
the biden administration
please help save the live free or die
state and our citizens
and i just have one quick response
to the previous speaker about the number
of rns that are vaccinated
well
yes 90 i don't i will accept the number
of ninety percent because because she
said so but
how many of those were coerced
vaccinations because nurses were told
take the job or lose your job
these are bread winners for their
families many of them
they nobody can make that decision how
immoral is it for someone to have to
make that choice between feeding their
children and clothing them and taking a
substance that you feel could be harmful
i don't believe that 90 percent would
have been reached without that coercion
and it was wrong
thank you janice i appreciate your input
any questions for janice
there being none thank you very much
janice
next up is stacy messina
i think it is dishes
good morning everybody thank you for
this opportunity um
i am currently living in pembroke new
hampshire with my two teenage kids and
my husband
um i haven't even been living in the
state for two months
we moved here from massachusetts i
lovingly refer to it as massachusetts
um
we came here
for you know the live free or diet
attitude we've been coming up here for
years for vacations and stuff and we
decided to move up here with
everything that was going on in
massachusetts seeing the handwriting on
the wall as a parent and watching what
was going on in the high school down
there that my children were in
they have a 90 percent
vaccination rate for the high school in
marblehead massachusetts and they were
still keeping the mass on the kids in
the last that i heard
um
they are moving to remove the masks for
the vaccinated children and the ones who
are not vaccinated have to keep the mask
talk about segregation
so
like i said i've been here a little over
a month and a half almost two months
i've been to every school committee
meeting
and i am horrified at what i've been
seeing
so i saw something yesterday that i just
wanted to read
briefly
and
it is
no single person including the president
of the united states should ever be
given the power to make a medical
decision for potentially millions of
americans
freedom over one's physical person is
the most basic freedom of all and people
in a free society should be sovereign
over their own bodies when we give
government the power to make medical
decisions for us we in essence accept
that the state owns our bodies
over
my cold dead body when it comes to my
children
that is all i have to say thank you very
much for this opportunity thank you
any questions
there being no questions thank you very
much
so again if anybody wants to speak in
the back of the room in the auntie room
are these pink cards this is what we're
doing our list from and and calling
people up by so if you want to um speak
and fill out the card and just drop it
off over here in the corner to
representative shaw who's all the way
hello thank you very much for taking my
testimony today
and for holding this hearing
my name is louise spencer
i was one of the folks outside
with the group holding signs that
vaccines are patriotic
because i believe that they they really
are
they help to promote the general welfare
which is also part of our constitution
i think they make a statement
that we live in a community and we need
to care for one another
and vaccines are one way to do that and
to keep things safe for us all
what i would really like to see coming
out of this committee
is a strong
policy statement that the state of new
hampshire supports and endorses vaccines
ideally people get vaccines
because they recognize that they serve a
really important purpose not only for
their own health but for the public
health in general
and
i think it's up to our leaders to set a
better example than has been happening
so far
about
what why we need to
encourage vaccines not only the covid
vaccine but we've seen throughout the
history of our country
how vaccines
have made a significant difference
in people's lives and in public health
that includes polio that includes
measles
that includes whooping cough
in fact my own daughter had whooping
cough after receiving one of the shots
and fortunately for her her doctor said
that because she had had at least one
of the shots
that it
at three months or six i guess she was
five months
um it prevented her from requiring
hospitalization
so vaccines
um have played a critical role
i'd like to see our leaders
really step up and counter the
misinformation that enables so many of
the statements that we're seeing here
so i would just also like to point out
that covet itself the coven 19
virus is a novel virus
and
people have we have no idea
what
how it's going to be in our bodies over
time and what damage it may do or when
it might re-assert itself
we see that happening with
the chickenpox virus which later in life
can re-emerge causing shingles this can
turn into a permanent
really painful situation my my husband
is a pain physician
and believe me it's one of the worst
pains that you can encounter is to have
chronic
shingles so
as much as we there may be things that
we don't know about the vaccine or the
virus we are learning
it is a novel virus
i think that science has come down
firmly on the side of the safety and
efficacy of this vaccine thank you very
much
thank you any questions for luis
go ahead
representative leon i have one thank you
very much for your testimony
do you have any high quality scientific
data to show that the other points of
view are misinformation
if you do i'd love to get those studies
sure i mean
i'm i'm not a physician myself but i i
certainly have
read plenty of
the
the layman's literature that's out there
i'd be happy to
provide you with some
some uh literature i it's abundant and
readily available and i'd be happy to
share some
okay
thank you sure
thank you anybody else
there being none thank you thank you
louise
next up is jeff howell
good morning and thank you for your time
this morning my name is jeff howell i am
from pelham new hampshire i've been a
new hampshire resident for 35 of the
last 40 years a graduate of unh i'm also
an engineer with 35 years of experience
now i did have a prepared statement to
read but as it deals a lot with my own
personal situation i will attempt to
summarize i'm here today to talk against
employer enforced mandates
and the detrimental
emotional
and financial impact it has on the
workers of new hampshire
i along with tens of millions
of other american workers across the
country have been forced
into a corporate mandate which i must
either comply with taking a covet
vaccine or i will face unemployment
without possibility of unemployment
this is happening these uh companies are
employing i think very abusive and
brutal uh
methods in order to enforce compliance
of their employees uh and i think this
is this is wrong um many employers in in
accordance with title vii of the 1964
civil rights act are allowing for
religious and medical accommodations
based on their reasons however millions
of many people who apply for these
religious exemptions are being subjected
to uh very
uh invasive and
invasions of their privacy uh both of
their religious beliefs and their
medical histories they get asked such
questions as uh do you routinely
participate in activities as part of
your faith uh what other medications or
treatments do you uh pose as a
consequence of your faith and uh what do
you just how do you justify taking other
medications you that use fetal cell
lines in their manufacture while still
refusing covert vaccines for the same
reason
um i believe that these products these
types of questions are very invasive of
people's personal
uh privacy and medical history rights i
find them very objectionable
and yet
companies are terminated employees after
asking after demanding they comply with
all of these these types of invasive
personal requests
i think this is this is this treatment
is very harassing it's very intimidating
it creates a very hostile work
environment for employees
um
and i think employees feel powerless in
order to combat this this results in a
great deal of anxiety
of undue stress and effectively uh
lowers their their ability to work and
these of these mandates are being
applied to employees regardless of their
situation it doesn't matter what their
job role is how often they interact with
their customers their clients their
suppliers their co-workers
it's just blanket across the board take
the jab or lose your job i think this is
needless to say creates a very very uh
discomforting effect for most people who
are engaged in it
they don't they can no longer perform
their jobs and these are being applied
regardless of whether or not people may
have exemplary job records they may have
nothing else against them in their job
but they're going to lose their jobs
simply because of their religious or
even perhaps medical reasons for not
wanting to take a vaccine
so
i just happen to disagree with all this
i think this is wrong i think employees
in new hampshire should be protected
from this side of harassment and i hope
that all these proposed legislations are
putting forward new hampshire will have
the courage to stand up to those
employer mandates and now in the future
and protect new hampshire workers from
these hostile and memorializing policies
thank you very much thank you jeff will
you take questions if anybody has any
uh representative leon i have one thank
you so much for your testimony
i was hoping that you could send some of
the information the questions that are
being asked by employers about their
religious history to the committee so we
can understand exactly how detailed
these questions are
i will i will endeavor to do that
however i will tell you that when i was
interviewed by my employer
they would not provide me the questions
in writing even though i asked them for
it so this is another one of the
harassing tactics that employers are
using they're taking all the information
from you they're making you stand
flat-footed and on a phone call and
start answering questions without any
preparation or anything else again very
uh disquieting and it was a very
uncomfortable procedure for me when i
went through it and i'm sure that
millions of other
new hampshire workers are facing the
same thing but i will i will put
together from what i can recall the
questions that were asked and send them
to the committee
thank you very much
anything else anybody else
what's that jeff jeff i will just give
you info so again on last wednesday we
had the business industry in and we were
speaking to various associations retail
and otherwise
um and there was some concern around
religious medical exemptions and the
fact that
um
you know we're putting businesses in a
really big bind you know with this
mandate and and religious exemptions
they
they've been told you know
if you sorry
um we heard from the i think it was the
surgeon general who said that they
believe that religious exemptions are
being abused
and they should be looked into and then
we also heard from from um
uh businesses saying now it puts them in
a bind with they if they
do a religious exemption are they gonna
be subject to some sort of audit because
of it does it create a
civil rights
liability issue for them so i do agree
that there is some problems around the
religious exemptions and having
businesses trying to decide whether or
not you're religious enough to qualify
for a religious exemption and that's
problematic
and even the businesses from the meeting
last week recognize that that is a an
issue that we have to look at and
address
thank you for i don't know can you hear
me thank you for taking my testimony i
appreciate the opportunity i'm going to
share my personal story with you just
speaking to the mic a little loud there
you go okay sorry
um
i'm united states air force veteran i am
a nurse of 30 years
in the last five years i've been a
visiting nurse for a home care health
and hospice agency providing home care
and hospice services to a variety of
people in franklin new hampshire
i also work part time as a nurse
sonographer
at haven pregnancy services
so
in march of 2020 like everyone you know
we were completely taken aback by coven
i
like everyone else didn't know what to
expect but i did not back down i
continued to work at my job despite the
fact that i could have taken on the role
of saying well i take care of my elderly
mom i have custody of my special needs
grandson i don't want to bring this
illness home to them so i will not
put myself out there but i did not do
that i continued to work i continued to
work without proper ppe because it was
not available
everybody knows the stories that
happened back then i don't need to
reiterate them but i worked diligently i
worked very hard
i'm an excellent employee i have
excellent recommendations
in november of last year i got coveted i
was sick for three weeks i was not
hospitalized but i was very very ill i
ended up with some side effects some
cardiopulmonary side effects some
neuropathic side effects
and
when the option came out to get the
vaccine i made a decision not to get the
vaccine based on the side effects and i
will review that with you in a moment
um
so i went back to work in december i
continued to work just as hard as i did
before i got sick
um
and you know
i just i i'm really really struggling
because
when the mandate came out
i applied for a religious exemption
i did everything just the right way i
was supposed to they told me that
religious exemptions were not
qualified under the biden administration
or medical exemptions which was not true
wasn't an accurate statement but i
researched it i did my
research i provided a letter of
religious exemption
for a variety of reasons
and it was denied and i was terminated
on october 28th
now they were sadder than i was when i
left i was given flowers i was given a
card telling me how wonderful i was and
how sorry they were that they had to let
me go but that they were fearful of uh
the fact that they would not be able to
allow me to go out into the community
despite the fact that i have natural
immunity and nobody is talking about
that which makes no sense because that
is the gold standard of
of
infection
um
but anyway so i i was terminated they
gave me
uh you know
uh no severance pay there was no
anything like that i i do have uh 240
hours of earn time so i will be okay for
a little while but that can explain to
you how hard i worked for them that i
never took vacation time i have that
much time left
so i just wanted to um and end a little
bit with just some really really
important details
so there has uh been many many studies
out there and you can look up studies
and you can find both sides right so
there's people saying no natural
immunity isn't valid and then there's
people saying yes it is and they're
saying no you the covid vaccine isn't
effective and then you see other people
other studies saying yes it is but i'm
going to provide you with some data that
i have found okay
the other thing i wanted to point out is
that there is no vaccine information
statement for covet 19 vaccine there is
a fact sheet available for each
different um
vaccine that is given
and on all of those they provide a
listing of possible side effects
including cardiac issues since i'm
already affected on a cardiopulmonary
basis i'm very short of breath whenever
i try to do any kind of exercise that
it's difficult to justify to myself
taking a vaccine that could cause me
more harm than good
so i just want to share these statistics
with you these were taken off the cdc
site from the vaccine adverse events
site this was pulled up last night
and i just wanted to share some things
with you so the mmr vaccine in the year
2021 with serious side effects reported
there were 23
and with uh
total side effects there have been
reported and that's for the measles
mumps and rubella
for the influenza vaccine the
quadrivalent in 2021 there have been 105
serious events reported
um
and in total there's been 2 394 events
for the coven 19 vaccine in the year
2021 there have been 55
314 serious
events a total of 522
303 events with a total of 577
617 total events reported to say that
there is no risk to getting the vaccine
is not true
and to make people
have to decide on their own health care
versus
taking this vaccine
is just not it's not
life liberty or the pursuit of happiness
goes against everything i
volunteered to go into the air force for
so i i respect
everybody's decision to make their own
right to the vaccine or not but when you
mandate it and you take away people's
jobs
i don't know what to say
so thank you for letting me tell my
story
thank you very much
any questions
[Applause]
any questions for deborah
seeing none deborah thank you very much
for telling the story
so i'll just let we have 17 more people
have signed up that's how many total
cards i have left so just as people
keeping it concise remember those three
words respect civil civility and
conciseness
next up is
patricia patricia myers
good morning thank you for your
willingness to serve this state i
appreciate that
okay tip the microphone up so i could
hear you
sorry
um
i just want to tell my testimony i had
kovid
i had it for two and a half days
i had the symptoms i know what the
symptoms were
it is not as dangerous as what we have
been led to believe we have been lied
to
throughout
because now
everyone has to have a vaccine for
what they cracked it up to be
i have a natural immunity no one with
whom i have been associated has come
not one
i have nurse friends
they come to me for help because they
don't want to take this vaccine because
they know what it's doing
they're in the hospital seeing people
who have had vaccines
sick with it
most of the people who come in with
these
with illnesses
have been vaccinated
because it doesn't protect you against
do you know what it's designed to do
it's designed to destroy your immune
system
what it does is it trains your natural
immunity to look only for the coveted
vacci the covid
it does not look for the variants it
trains your immune system to
ignore everything but that
virus
so if you get anything else you're going
this is not a conspiracy
we're here now
a conspiracy is only a conspiracy until
when these people are unemployed let go
they're suspended without pay do you
know what that means
i have no more words for this is so
disgusting
it's so corrupt
i have no words
anybody have any questions for patricia
we're all set thank you patricia
appreciate it
next up is jennifer smith dr jennifer
smith from the new hampshire public
so thank you for taking testimony from
us um
i
have a lot to say but i'll try to keep
it really brief
um there is
a lot of
i i don't know what to really call it
what what what seems to me to be
entirely misinformed opinion being
shouted can we just speak up a little
i am double masked which i don't usually
do but since i'm in a room full of
people who are not mad
for quite a bit bit of time um i i
made it
fully um and i
just want to point some things out
that
and and by the way the question about
getting statistics i'm sure that our
department of public health services
would be happy to supply you statistics
but looking at national statistics which
i do every morning
the the current
finding is that people who are
vaccinated still have a risk no
vaccination is 100
protective
and
so health care workers especially really
need to vaccinate
to protect others
and we've had mandates in health care
systems for vaccine for a long time
and
i i can remember in fact when i was a
intern and started serving on policy
committee for infectious infection
control at the hospital in connecticut
where i was trained
that we actually had to go through the
process of deciding about that for
rubiola that is in fact german measles
and you think about it for a while and
you go you know
all it takes is one health care worker
in contact with a pregnant woman to end
up with
the baby that i once saw
at another hospital in connecticut who
would never develop into anything
other than a small
sick
child um
who would never be able to
do much of anything and so it's kind of
like mandates are necessary
in some situations and
there is already by the way a court case
being brought by the state of new
hampshire and multiple other states so
this committee does not need to
recommended the legislature do anything
that case will find its way to the u.s
supreme court eventually
and i think they will probably find i
hope with the same
rationale that happened over a hundred
years ago that the state can mandate
vaccines for people
and there is actually an alternative at
this point for people who don't want
vaccines and that is to get themselves
tested
regularly believe it's weekly i've
forgotten but
the evidence for
problems
from this vaccine
compared to the evidence for problems
for getting coveted which is still
rampant in this state
is really thin
and
for instance the myocarditis
pericarditis that has occurred in some
mostly young men
has all recovered 100 percent have
recovered
and that can't be said for even young
men who've had coded
very very tiny percentage of people with
poor immune competence for unknown
reasons who didn't know that have died
at young ages including children by the
way
and
right now this
epidemic of the unvaccinated yes it does
in fact
it affects some of us who are vaccinated
but it's about six times as likely that
the unvaccinated will get
infected
and pass it on by the way
and 12 times it's likely that they will
die and there is so much misinformation
out there that some
people
who really would benefit from the
vaccination have decided not to get it
i would urge you not to do anything that
will interfere
with further public health efforts and
i just had one little historical thing
to say
but aside from my own experience as a
child we were just so
happy to have polio vaccine
you know it probably would have been an
emergency use authorization at the time
it had that been the way things worked
but it was not better study than this
it was a new novel technology
and if you go back all the way to the
birth of this country there are
good historians who think we wouldn't
have this country
if general washington hadn't gone
against
a lot of people's
fear
and mandated immunization of all the
troops
in 1777
because smallpox was rampant
and
bringing new recruits into his camp was
going to be a huge problem if people
weren't vaccinated so he did it against
a lot of public opinion
and it worked
so bear those kinds of things in mind
thank you
thank you uh willing to take questions
doctor
and we have a question with the doctor
representative leon um thank you so much
for your testimony in the historic
context uh do you know what the fatality
rate was for smallpox oh way higher than
this there's no question that this is a
much less lethal virus however people
are
i think it's somewhere around 700 or 750
000 in this country alone
millions across the world
have died of this virus
so it isn't trivial do i know the exact
fatality rate that changes over time as
we've gotten better at treatment
and we now
soon we'll have a pill that actually is
effective we actually have one that's
been shown in one study luvox
antidepressant that's been shown to be
pretty damp defective
but all the other treatments
no they have not
so
it's it's a
ongoing
story
and by the way um the the
the idea that it is not protective
against variants is not true
the vast majority of people who have
been fully vaccinated
with
mrna vaccines
are protected against the current
variance
justice almost as well as against the
original although it's hard to tell
again because you've got this
progression and
ability to do good medical care
knowledge of things like prone
positioning
being very life-saving
those things weren't known when we
started
well if i could follow up will
availability of that that new therapy
for covid that reduces the burden
disease burden make a difference for you
in terms of mandating the vaccine i have
no idea until it's out there
it's not out there yet so we'll see data
matters and if i may just have one more
um you speak to the polio vaccine do you
know if it was the jonas salk vaccine
that eliminated polio or if it was a
different eliminated polio from the
world
it comes back into this country
periodically
very sporadically thank god
yes it is in the soil it started with an
oral vaccine
it was extremely effective and it is
actually still the strategy of
preference there is a side effect
potential and again i've forgotten the
exact statistics that some immune
systems and some small children are
incompetent and they will get polio from
the vaccine
but overall
it has driven down the numbers of polio
cases remarkably
we in this country switched from oral to
injectable because it does not have that
risk but it is not as effective
in suppressing outbreaks and so in
places where there are still outbreaks
pakistan nigeria
places like that
they use the
oral and some places have
done a combined strategy
injectable and then oral later
and are you aware that those are not the
salk vaccine those are actually the
sabin vaccine that was developed because
there was letter ans asked the question
and you can answer the question that the
saben vaccine was developed with the
help of jonas salk using unvaccinated
populations and had the salk vaccine
been forced upon the whole world we
never would have seen the saben vaccine
or is that just a consequence of history
that
answer and i don't know which is salt
and which is saving we just think of
oral and injectable when we talk about
them
thank you
just as it comes to the lawsuits do you
do know that um as of friday there are
two lawsuits pending in front of the i
believe it's the fifth circuit
one of which is on the executive orders
uh the mandate for federal contractors
under executive orders and then there's
a second lawsuit that was filed
regarding the osha violation and new
hampshire's joined both those lawsuits
opposing the mandates under both
executive order and osha mandates so if
you didn't know that that um our
attorney general has signed on to both
of those
next up is amy ellis
amy
good morning
my name is amy ellis i am a wife and
mother of two boys and a proud citizen
of the livery or die state
my hope in prayer and speaking today is
that everyone will listen and take the
time to consider and understand
why we are opposed to the vaccine
mandates
a point of view that has been largely
dismissed and discredited if not
completely censored
the mainstream media has cruelly tried
to put and keep us all in a perpetual
state of fear
in regards to covid19 and anyone opposed
to the vaccine while one opinion is
repeated over and over
the other is completely removed from the
conversation
dr asset levy said doctors and
scientists who disagree with the safety
and effectiveness of this so-called
vaccine are met with hostility rejection
and even elimination from government
media and the scientific community
itself
this censorship
is a fact and should deeply concern
everyone
despite the threat of losing one's
life's work career and livelihood many
have bravely stepped forward to fight
for our right as we know
i'm sorry to know as we will know as
much as possible at this va of this
vaccine
they have very literally pledged to us
all their lives their fortunes and their
sacred honor they have everything to
lose and still speak out
i have learned enough about the possible
side effects of taking this vaccine to
know it is far too soon for my comfort
to take this injection
this should remain my choice
as with all drugs we are given a list of
side effects
as the consumers and we can choose to
avoid them if we feel this risk is too
high
for myself and certainly my children as
of now the risks far outweigh the reward
this choice does not
make me selfish
or uneducated contrary to the popular
narrative it also doesn't mean i love my
kids family friends and neighbors any
more or less than someone who chooses
this vaccine
to those who have chosen to take this
vaccine i am grateful you are able to be
given that peace of mind if it is as
wonderful as they say and i pray it is
then you need to rest assured in your
decision and trust its effectiveness
i pray you will all have the grace
patience and compassion to understand my
reservations and sincere concerns in
this vaccine and the consequences of
mandating any injection never mind in
brand new vaccine with an unusually high
rate of side effects
i will never judge another mother or
father's personal or private choice of
whether or not to get this vaccine we
are all doing what we feel is best based
on the information we have available
we all need to be critical thinkers dig
deep for all viewpoints especially those
that are being so desperately and
deliberately concealed and respect each
other's conclusions
mass right excuse me mass and rush
vaccinations have robbed us of the time
necessary to determine real adverse
reactions
we are being manipulated to take a brand
new so-called vaccine and will have no
recourse whatsoever if we are injured by
it this is an outrage
whether time shows this vaccine is good
or not history will show that the
mandates are wrong
mandating this vaccine will absolutely
lead to a precedent we will only
understand once it is too late
we are all americans we cannot lose our
humility and empathy for each other
live free or die
and god bless america
[Applause]
thank you for that testimony is there
any are there any questions
thank you
good morning and thank you for this
opportunity to allow all of us to speak
i'm here
the current vaccine or back shot as i
would prefer to call it for use for
covid does not prevent you from getting
the disease
does not prevent you from spreading the
disease to others
and if you have an adverse reaction
there is no recourse
so the reason i am not calling it a
vaccine is the cdc changed their
definition of a vaccine
originally the vaccine was a product
that stimulates a person's immune system
to produce immunity
to a specific disease
protecting that person from the disease
in august 31st they changed their
vaccine
definition to a preparation that is used
to stimulate the body's immune system
that is ill
it does not protect you from that
disease
and there have been many adverse
reactions and deaths
in the current bears report dated
october 29th
in the united states there have been
eighteen thousand over eighteen thousand
deaths
and over twenty eight thousand who have
now a permanent disability
the other
thing i'd like to speak to is the
emergency use authorization
that is used to allow unapproved medical
products if there are no approved or
available alternatives
i have attached papers in my documents
from the national institute of health
regarding hydroxychloroquine and
ivermectin
both
and then a decision from the nebraska
attorney general on their state being
allowed to use these off-label drugs to
treat covid
attorney general from nebraska have said
that there are alternatives to the
vaccine
why do we continue to have an emergency
youth authorization
the mandate is unethical for a variety
of reasons but
primarily because it tramples over the
fundamental principle of bodily autonomy
and individual agency when it becomes
comes to personal health
yes the vaccine may be safe for some
and one can make a reasonable case that
getting vaccinated may be a good choice
for some but that's what it should be a
personal choice
the mandate is unconstitutional because
there is no basis in the constitution
which lets the executive branch
of power and authority to compel private
businesses to take these actions
the president
and the executive branch like the
department of labor are not legislative
bodies
they have no power to make law
their job is to faithfully execute the
laws duly acted enacted by our
legislative body
our legislature
and then i just want to close with
the voluntary consent of the human is
absolutely essential this means that the
person involved
should have the legal capacity to give
consent should be able to exercise free
power of choice
without intervention of any element of
force
fraud deceit duress
overreaching or other ulterior form of
constraint and should have sufficient
knowledge and comprehension of the
subject to enable him to make an
enlightened decision
thank you very much for your time
seeing none we'll move on thank you
susan
next up is amanda
oh i'm gonna butcher that last name
mastro
sorry i truly apologize amanda mastroni
that's okay
with all the progress that our country
has made in regards to civil rights it's
disdainful that we would have u.s
citizens moving to different states due
to the abuses that its current state
inflicts upon them in regards to medical
choice
it's disdainful to think that my
children
wouldn't be able to play sports or
engage in after school activities
because our religion refuses certain
medical treatments this is happening in
cambridge massachusetts
it's disdainful to think that my
children would not be allowed to attend
school because their religion prohibits
certain medical treatments this is
happening in connecticut
and california
it's horrifying to think that my
children would be seriously limited in
their choice of occupation solely
because they refuse to receive an
injection
those who follow certain religions are
being treated as second-class citizens
their livelihoods are being taken away
it's also horrifying that people who
simply do not choose to trust the fda or
the cdc
in regards to what they put in or on
their bodies are being discriminated
against and segregated from others
personally i've had a mistrust in
western medicine
for over 20 years that is not to say
that there aren't some aspects of
western medicine
that have their benefits
however i have had personal experiences
multiple times where i was being plagued
with various symptoms and went to many
doctors to get answers
far too often their recommendations
either did nothing or made matters worse
more often than not my ailments were
healed by seeking alternative measures
namely eliminating certain drinks and
incorporating more fruit specials earth
herbs and supplements
none of which were recommended to me by
doctors who were covered by my so-called
health insurance
so even if this vaccine were not against
my religion my family and i would still
be subject to the discrimination based
on our conscientious objection
my past experiences and my religion are
not the only reason i reject certain
medical interventions
many seem to be behaving as if the cdc
and the fda and the pharmaceutical
companies
have a perfect track record
i can assure you they don't
many products have been recalled from
the fda that had been approved
because they were injuring or killing
people
the fda does not deserve my trust
the cdc
advertised that pregnant women should
get the flu vaccine meanwhile there were
no safety studies for that vaccine in
pregnant women not one
so it is unethical for them to claim
such things
the cdc does not deserve my trust
the pharmaceutical companies cannot be
the pharmaceutical company said that
they would no longer make vaccines
anymore if they did not get such
protection from the government
why
because they were losing too much money
in the lawsuits with people who were
injured by the vaccines
so now taxpayer dollars pay big pharma
for the vaccines and taxpayer dollars
also pay those seeking compensation
for vaccine injuries
i don't know about you but if i were
vaccine injured i would not look for
compensation because i know
that it wouldn't be coming from the
companies that created the product that
as i'm sure many of you have seen veers
bears you
also probably heard that it's not
reliable
well since it's the only reporting
system that health care workers are
bound by law to report vaccine injuries
to
i will be choosing to believe every one
of those reports until proven otherwise
or until these agencies that are
supposedly adept enough to tell us which
medical treatments are safe
become smart enough to develop a
reliable reporting system
but even if only half of those injuries
were legit
that's far too many to be creating
vaccine mandates
then one must consider the harvard study
which you can find on the nih website
that talks about how only about one
percent of vaccine injuries actually get
reported
where there is risk there must be choice
furthermore there's this matter of
natural immunity
in many countries they are recognizing
natural immunity as a medical exemption
meaning if an individual has antibodies
they are not required to get vaccinated
there are over 100 studies that say
natural immunity is equal to or
protection that the vaccines are
currently providing
then there are those
when there are those that are fully
vaccinated that are getting and
spreading covet any mandate is
absolutely useless
there are people with natural immunity
losing their jobs because they refuse
the vaccine
my husband a crane operator has been
denied certain jobs because he is not
vaccinated
meanwhile he is naturally immune which
means he offers more support for herd
immunity than vaccinated individuals
my husband isn't even given the
opportunity to show that he is natural
naturally immune
it is very easy to test for antibodies
he is also given no opportunity to
submit a religious exemption
so not only is this madness against the
constitution
but the discrimination is completely and
utterly unwarranted
so i have developed a mistrust in anyone
penalize the unvaccinated
when those who make up the unvaccinated
population
have done their due diligence
following their conscious
following their religion or they are
naturally immune and therefore do not
thank you thank you
seeing none thank you very much amanda
my name is mike burkett i'm from hudson
good morning ladies and
gentlemen uh i'd like to speak not only
on my behalf but also of my two sons
their wives and my five grandchildren
new hampshire residents
i am also the voice for many of my
construction co-workers tradesmen and
friends
i would like to thank you for this open
hearing so that we might be able to air
our concerns over the present situation
we all find ourselves to be in
what started out as a two-week mask
mandate has become 18 months
we are all living under a cloud of
oppression it would seem with no end in
sight and seemingly about to worsen
we have all had to alter our lives to
some degree
in order to push forward in an attempt
to get back to some sort of normality
i am one of many who was not willing to
accept the new norm as normal which is
why we have come here today
with that said you probably can figure
out where i stand in regards to the
outright federal overreach being forced
upon us
covet has been labeled as a pandemic a
pandemic is defined as a large epidemic
an epidemic is the rapid spread of a
disease to a large number of people in a
short amount of time
i believe that covid should be labeled
as an endemic and doc you can
elaborate on that if you'd like
but
an epidemic is the rapid spread of a
disease to a large number of people in a
short amount of time i believe that
covid should be labeled as an endemic a
disease
that continues to be present within a
geographical area but its impact is
manageable
the draconian measures taken to combat
this virus
were not based totally on scientific
statistics that had a solid base
an example of this is the number of
deaths attributed to covert 19 without
co-morbidity factors
the mandate by definition can't be
authority granted by a cons constituency
to act as its representative the
constituents to the best of my knowledge
and understanding have not given any
authority to act on their behalf with a
38 percent approval raising rating as of
sunday night how can this ever be
set forth as a mandate
this is dictatorial socialist government
on display
federal government overreach is what we
are experiencing as a nation the tenth
amendment reads quote the powers not
delegated to the us
by the constitution nor prohibited by
the states
reserve to the states respectively or to
the people it was originally drafted to
quell fears at the federal government
through congress would grow beyond its
delegated powers and interfere with the
governing powers of the states and the
natural rights of the people
justice roberts in 2012 noted the tenth
amendment press on what might at first
seem a
counter-interactive insight
that freedom is enhanced by the creation
of two governments not one
and that was the national federation of
independent businesses versus sebelius
in 2012. the tenth amendment was
designed as a practical method for
protecting individual rights
my desire in speaking here this morning
is to show the attempt of the federal
government
to disregard my rights as an individual
the rights of businesses
and owners and to have control over
their own employees in regards to this
newly adopted osha regulation
we all know that the quote hundred
employee threshold is only the cracked
to have an inroad into all businesses
i want to give a few statistics
to give a clearer perspective of where
we are as a state
all information is from the new
hampshire employment security updated
november 7th
these are the numbers for the first
quarter of 2021.
i've taken the liberty to round off the
numbers
businesses with 50 to 99 employees
are 1030 average average weekly wage
20 to 49 employees 3 000
average weekly rage wage 1130
10 to 19 employees 4 300
average weekly wage 1160
five to nine employees 6 500 businesses
average weekly rate wage
1200.
one to four
twenty four thousand six hundred
employees
average weekly wage nineteen hundred
dollars
then you go to one hundred or more
employees there's fourteen hundred
businesses the weekly wage is twelve
hundred plus or minus
about fifty percent of the employees
work in a business of a hundred or more
in this state the vaccination percentage
of adults from 25 to 64
is approximately 45.
this age group represents the majority
of the workforce in the state all
numbers are from the usa facts dated
november 5th at less than 50 percent of
the workforce being vaccinated and 50
percent of the state's wage earners
belonging to the mandatory vaccination
group it is
easy to see that the impact this will
have on your
i think it is safe to assume that anyone
who wanted to get vaccinated in this
state would have the opportunity to get
it by now
if this regulation is passed it will
have a large impact on the people of
this state
this will affect me personally because i
work for a construction company with
more than 100 employees
i will not take the shot for reasons i
will explain shortly
and tradesmen
feel the same
some are here today it costs us a day's
pay to be here but we wanted our voices
to be heard the thought of losing my job
is very concerning but the principle
here is tyrannical my two sons also will
be affected in the same way one of them
whose wife is a physical therapist told
me that she has to be tested twice a
week because she has
refused the shot and she has a religious
exemption
and so she's able to keep working
her sister had worked as an rna
at a skilled nursing facility in bedford
for a few years she just got her rn
certificate and two weeks later was
fired for refusing to get the shot
this was two months ago there are
hundreds of similar instances that can
be heard that have the same outcome
we should have the final say as to what
goes into our body not some bureaucrat
in washington as the pro-abortion crowd
likes to claim it's my body it's my
choice
my reasons for being
unvaccinated are one the use
of aborted fetal tissue number two
insufficient testing number three
inability to factually support all of
its benefits number four natural
immunity five negative side effects six
obtain viral antibodies seven i am
healthy with no cold cold morbid
morbidity factors sorry i'm having
trouble with that one so my questions
are why should i get vaccinated if i
already had covet an israeli study
stated that the antibodies
built up after contracting the virus are
17 times better than getting the vaccine
why should i get vaccinated if i have
natural immunity
the studies are incomplete but there are
indications that certain blood types
give greater protection against the
virus than others
why should i want to trust the fda who
has recalled consumer products he all
know about roundup
and just last week two blood pressure
medicines were recalled because of
possible carcinogenic implications
why the recall because further more
extensive testing in a broader scope
this vaccine
was rushed through approved by the fda
um
but we will not know the long-term side
effects for this for many many years
what about herd immunity
the amish in lancaster council county
pennsylvania hit it head on
you can watch an interview
at full measure with cheryl atkinson
amish covent
it's a short video and it explains how
they handled this situation they hit it
head on
finally
what about the side effects
if you've not heard about some of the
side effects of this shot you need to
take your
your head out of the sand
there are many incidences of people
having adverse short and long-term side
effects after getting the vaccination
one lady i talked to told me of four
female friends who have had their female
cycles altered after getting the shot
all four were nurses who were forced to
there are many who have developed blood
clots
that have
subsequently led to strokes and heart
attacks others have ongoing issues
negatively affecting them causing loss
of work time
at last count
there were around twenty thousand deaths
i watched a video saturday night
that i would like to bring to everyone's
attention and with this i will finish
the interview is with dr john campbell
and kyle mears it is 42 minutes long and
it is well worth the watch
meers it
mears is a professional mountain biker
he's 29 years old in peak perfect
physical condition on june 2nd he got
his second dose of pfizer vaccine two
weeks later
his resting heart rate was 25 higher
than normal
and and he knows this because he
monitors everything because he does
things worsened
and he ended up in the hospital with a
heart rate of 160 sustained at 135 for
two hours
after several trips back and forth to
the hospital numerous doctor's
appointments he was diagnosed with
pericarditis and pots
he has been virtually housebound for
four months reactive arthritis continues
to plague him
he ended up hearing of other people's
reaction because of his
popularity in the mountain biking crowd
and found many people having similar
reactions he has started a support group
online called react 19 to help others in
need
on january 4th i will be fired from my
job i've been there 32 years i don't
blame them for it
they are forced to do so because of the
unjustifiable fines they will have to
pay which by the way
is upwards of fourteen thousand dollars
what's worse they will lose at least 25
to 35 percent of their workforce
i would certainly be able to claim a
religious exemption but there are no
the vaccine does not prevent you from
getting the virus nor does it prevent
the recipient from spreading it so why
get it for me a healthy fit man i'll
take my chances but it should be a
choice that i make based on fact and
conviction not coercion and fear of
retribution
we have no motorcycle helmet law in this
state it's a choice for each rider a
risk
each one takes to bear it or not to wear
it or not which i think exemplifies our
model
if these mandates and regulations are
upheld and enacted we will have to have
another one of these public hearings to
discuss a new motto for our state
because live free or die would be a
false statement a lie
thank you
thank you michael any questions from
michael
there being none thank you michael very
much
mighty tall people in here
good morning my name is paula johnson
um i live in nashua and i want to say
everybody who's testified today has made
extraordinary great points here
you know we live in a state that the
model is live free or die
i came to this state over 40 years ago
and you can still hear my new york
accent and i thank god every day i'm not
with bill de blasio down in new york
i also sat and represented paul from
2005 to 2006
and these are our forefathers that gave
us our freedom
that wants to be taken away from us
because our president who's not my
president and i'm going to say this
because everybody said when president
trump was in there that he wasn't their
president
he did not give us mandates like this
which is not a law
you cannot mandate people to take a
vaccine i can't because i have
autoimmune and i don't like to talk
about my health condition i have been
discriminated against at my job because
i cannot wear a mask i haven't worked
since august 16th and i've been fighting
with them i'm losing my job most likely
this week because i cannot wear a mask
because of health issues i go into panic
attacks now
is that right to do to us to people
we did not create this pandemic this
came from the wuhan labs with dr fatchi
who has taken out money and has caused
all this
and when you listen to one of the
speakers who said
we were supposed to be inside for two
weeks to flatten the curve
oh hey people what the hell is going on
here
where's the curve there is no curve
anymore my husband lost his job
he had to get a new job
i thank the federal government for
giving us so much money that we the
people deserve because we work for all
this money so they just gave us a big
refund wasn't that nice of them
but when you think about the reality ask
all you
committee members who took money from
pfizer immersed
who took it because i know which senate
is dead
why don't we start exposing each and
every one of them right now
because you know what you can't sit on
this committee or vote
and vote honestly because you've been
bought and paid for we all know it man
excuse me let's stick to the policy not
the people
to the policy not the people thank you
and when you first opened up the meeting
you had a list of all i was trying to
write everything down but i couldn't why
should children who have zero percent of
getting covert have to wear masks in
school
they shouldn't
what are they doing to the psyche of
these children
these kids that had to be out of school
for a year year and a half
mentally
suicide
they forgot what their friends looked
like
matter of fact on election day in nashua
i was talking to an alderman we were six
feet apart all of a sudden he says to me
are you vaccinated
none of his business nobody needs to
know if it's true or false i said no
next thing i know he walked six feet
away but i was six feet away from him
anyway and he had a mask on so if these
masks work
why
do people have to be vaccinated if
they're vaccinated why do they have to
still wear mass because dr facchi said
that's what we have to do keep getting
jab keep getting jabbed keep getting
jabbed and we don't know what the
long-term effects are on these children
that's right they're coming for our kids
now
my kids i'm grateful they're all grown
but i got small grandchildren now i look
at these poor and innocent faces
that never know anything
about racism until we teach it to them
they love everybody
but what happens to them
they go out into the real world and then
we lose them
and then we poison their brains with
everything
and then we have the mask mandate and
then what are we going to do say the
kids can't come to school and they have
another immunization well let's talk
about immunizations what about the mmr
when the doctor said she with her double
mask she couldn't understand anything
she was talking about and you say
that
you're going to put me on your facebook
page i don't want to be on your facebook
page please
i don't want to be on your facebook page
i don't care i don't want to be on your
fake news page ma'am
again go back to policy let's talk about
policy
[Applause]
and then what do we do to these poor
kids we mask them up at school they
can't see their friends
we vaccinate them and the mmr and we
know about what happened with the mmr
autism autism and i remember my oldest
son
in the 1980s and i watched phil donahue
by today's standards he'd probably be
super liberal i don't know but he talked
about the pertussis and the brain damage
and you saw these poor children in the
wheelchair
and your heart broke because these were
innocent lives
and then we i heard that other doctor
what was her name dr smith i think it
was i got notes everywhere dr smith
and she talked about polio and she
talked about all the other vaccines
well you know if you get you know nurses
you get shingles you can use lemon balm
you know
if you get sick i think i had covert in
march of 2020 i was deadly ill
i asked my doctor four or five times do
you want to test me and she said no you
don't have the symptoms what up let's
talk about the symptoms
the symptoms are like the flu
the same thing as a flu they didn't have
enough symptoms so they threw stomach
aches in there so if kids go to school
and they don't feel good they go home
and they have to be tested for covet and
they've got to be tested they've got to
be tested well
what happened when the flu went around
the schools we didn't disinfect and we
didn't master kids or the teachers and
we have more deaths
from the flu for kids and teachers
depending on which flu was what about
the normal virus
what happens with that
people come off the cruise ship that's
deathly ill and it goes rampant through
the nursing homes and it's very
disrespectful if anybody be texting when
people are talking
and so
what happens with that we never messed
people up we never disinfected
and so you have to really take a look at
what has covert done to us
the reset on the economy
that's what it was all supposed to be
we've masked everybody we have employee
mandates employer mandates that people
going to lose their jobs
we have now the trucking industry
i was listening to
attorney um lee
dundas i don't know if anybody knows who
she is she's in california civil rights
that from today for four days they're
going to start shutting down the
trucking industry because of employee
mandates well guess what two weeks
before thanksgiving is here you better
go stock up in your house now and hoard
the food
and then what's coming up christmas
and who are gonna get hurt the poor kids
again it comes back to we the people
it comes back to these children that are
in schools and most schools do not have
any policy
for medical
or religious for these students not to
wear a mask and to not to have to take
vaccines and that's the next thing
that's going to happen it's about time
that our legislature stands up because
we
for a year and a half had a life of hell
in this state when our governor
continuously had these executive orders
and in those executive orders 74 it
exempted a lot and people with
disabilities that did not have to wear
mass that were forced upon in the city
of nashua
even with more medical reasons you had
to bring a note although executive order
74 said you did not have executive order
said that teachers students and
administrators didn't have to wear masks
oh but they did
so where are we going here people
we elected you to represent us not to
represent the administration not to
represent the governor to represent all
of us in this audience and i know people
because i've been at so many rallies
you've been elected to protect us from
big pharma
but although many people i think
everybody in the senate has taken big
dollars from pfizer
and other companies so how can you vote
how can you vote to protect us even the
governor took ninety three thousand
dollars worth of fisa money
so how can he be there for us we the
people and you might say it's not part
of this but it really is
because when you take money from
lobbyists you are no longer representing
us we the people that we vote all of you
in you work for all of us and we
shouldn't have to be standing here and
rallying time after time after time for
our rights our protection from the state
and federal government and even from the
local municipalities
we the people remember that it's we the
people you work for us
and it's about time you start working
for us because we've had enough enough
of this covert enough of the mass enough
of the mandates telling us that we have
to be vaccinated in either to work to go
on a plane to go into a store it's gonna
happen to have the quality of life
because that's what's been taken away
from us our quality of life thank you
next up is
again i
remind everybody about time and
conciseness
if you're bringing up new points or just
uh hit hit
points they've already been said
hi my name is eliza hale i live in
nashua new hampshire thank you
for the opportunity to speak in this
public comment session
i'm a resident of new hampshire and also
work in the health care system here in
our state both my husband and i are
directly impacted
by the current covid vaccine mandates
brought on by the federal government
the current state of events in this
country has blessed me with relearning
as an adult the constitution both the
u.s and new hampshire's constitution
our founding fathers built our country
and our state on the ground that each
man and woman has natural inherent
rights to life liberty and ultimately
seeking and obtaining happiness
we are protected in the constitution
from discrimination based on our race
creed color sex or national origin
so as far to my knowledge nowhere in the
constitution does it state that our
government has any rights to our body
in fact to my knowledge the constitution
does exactly the opposite stating we
have the right to live free from
government intrusion
in private or personal information
and this is a natural and inherent right
meaning they are
pre-ex pre-existing the government
these rights are meant to protect the
citizens
but yet
we are all here
fighting for something we already have
i am not here
today because i know how to define a
medical intervention i really wish i did
i will continue to pray for each of you
on this committee
i am here to stand up for my natural
inherent rights i am here to urge the
legislation to protect those rights the
the federal government has overstepped
its reach massively
the state of new hampshire has the power
to protect us its citizens from these
mandates that will surely change the
landscape of this great state in many
negative ways i cannot speak to every
field of work
but i can to our health care system as i
has been in it for 18 years
our workforce has been hit very hard
over the last 18 months
and if we are not protected from the
current mandates the federal government
is attempting to place on us our health
care in new hampshire will be hit even
harder
losing even more of its workforce what
then
what will happen if you have an injury
or a loved one that is gravely ill
i honestly do not know how we will be
able to provide adequate and safe health
care to this state
if things continue moving in this
direction
i am not here begging for you to save my
job or anyone else's but i am here to
stand up and demand the legislator in
this legislature in this state protect
its citizens
and the constitution thank you thank you
not seeing any thank you eliza
thank you members of the committee for
serving on this important topic
i'm here today to
[Music]
testify for my son who
fortunately could not be here and i say
fortunately because he still has a job
he's working today
unfortunately he's going to be
terminated within within three weeks
as
a worker who
works in a very
under-appreciated underpaid overworked
job as a
mental health counselor at a large new
hampshire
organization
i'm very proud of him he works in a very
noble profession
hr has considered this a voluntary
resignation
only to allow him to
receive compensation for unused vacation
time
he will do okay
in the end but
i'm worried about his own mental health
right now
and this is a state
and probably across the nation as well
where mental health
is considered a
problem for states
countries counties everywhere
and now there will be one less mental
health counselor available for
people who are truly in need
he started to say goodbye to his
long-term clients
of 10 years
he's had to make the announcement to his
associates
people have talked earlier about how
businesses will suffer
and i can't speak to that but i know by
mental health
organizations will be
losing a very good worker
and i'm i'm sad for that
i can't speak to the businesses of
new hampshire that are undergoing these
mandates but others have
and we will continue to see probably
deterioration in the workforce
i just like to address some of the
personal
effects of
mandates
mandates have allowed people to shame
the unvaccinated
former friends of ours i won't say
former i will say
friends who are
maybe less friendly now
have actually said
in a group
we should find out who's unvaccinated
and shame them
no amount of shaming is going to
make people
take a vaccination that they have every
right to refuse
we will never reach
herd immunity through vaccination except
that fact
it will not happen
we all know when we go into different
stores
we see the signs
you must wear a mask if you're
unvaccinated
i wear a mask if i'm unvaccinated or not
i'm worried about the vaccinated people
i've got a mask on today but i took it
off to speak
i work about i worry about vaccinated
people who are gathering and pretending
things are all normal thinking that
they're
they're at no risk to transmit the
lastly i think about isolation
we think twice about gathering with our
friends
the topic of vaccination will come up
inevitably
and we feel embarrassed but why should
we it's time to stop that it's time to
educate the vaccinated people that
yeah well we're not more at risk than
you are
we find our own tribe we've i've found a
lot of new friends today i don't know
them but they're already friends of mine
in closing i'd like to say that
we all must hold very strongly the
belief that we have a right to medical
freedom
this is medical freedom for all
we're at
peril and i'd like to use the phrase
that my
niece has used in the past
by the way
she has already lost her job at mass
general hospital she's a medical
oncologist
she feels that her body is more
important than a job
she's
given up her job and will be looking for
she uses the phrase dark and sinister
and i use that phrase a lot now what is
happening now is dark and sinister
be careful of what is going to follow
we're living in a dark and sinister
world if we allow these things to happen
thank you gary any questions for mr york
not seeing any thank you very much sir
and thank you for your son and daughter
service in the healthcare field
[Music]
hi
thank you to the committee for holding
this discussion could you speak step a
little closer to them thank you thank
you to the committee for holding this
hearing on such an important topic
and also thank you to the many speakers
for your eloquence and passion which is
so inspiring to me personally
so my name is risa evans and i live in
kentucky with my
husband and daughter and our dogs
i'm a lawyer and i also teach over at
the law school i teach legal writing
as you may know the university of new
hampshire recently mandated vaccines for
all employees because it is a federal
contractor
so as will become obvious the views that
i am expressing here today are my own
and not my employers
i think that vaccine mandates and
vaccine passports are a terrible idea
and that the censorship coercion
discrimination and scapegoating that
surround them pose a far greater threat
to humanity than does covet 19 itself
the committee has heard a lot of
testimony very compelling about the
individual costs of these mandates and i
would like to just spend a few minutes
talking about how the costs to society
as a whole
far outweigh any claimed public health
benefits and why we should do everything
that we can here in new hampshire to
keep vaccine mandates out
so first about the cost to society
i think we're all seeing as a result of
expanding system of vaccine mandates we
are increasingly becoming a segregated
two-tiered society
and i think it's important to fully
imagine what this means not just right
now but also in the months and years
ahead if we don't put a stop to this so
let's do that
on the one hand we have people who for a
variety of very good reasons
have not and will not comply with the
mandates
if you fall into this category like so
many people here you find yourself
increasingly barred from your own life
as the efforts to obtain your compliance
lead to exclusion from key aspects of
civil society such as jobs schools
travel places of worship and more
and because government mandates are
always backed up by enforcement
mechanisms if the soft coercion doesn't
work
down the road there's always the
possibility of force whatever that might
look like
so on the other hand we have people who
have complied with the mandates whether
under duress or because as it is for
many people vaccination was the right
choice for them
if you fall into this category society
is open to you you're free to access
education employment travel
entertainment and so on there's just one
catch
your medical passport needs to be fully
up to date
when it expires it's time for another
booster
until you get that booster you no longer
count as fully vaccinated
and if you don't get it if you start to
question
the efficacy or safety or necessity for
more boosters
you are relegated to the ranks of the
non-compliant with all that entails
now some people might say that however
dystopian this vision such a society is
worth it because vaccine mandates are
necessary to protect public health and
to end the pandemic
and on this point i would disagree
like many well-credentialed independent
scientists and physicians around the
globe i believe that the three public
health justifications that are claimed
in support of vaccine mandates just
don't cut it
first vaccine mandates can't and won't
lead to hurt immunity as evidenced by
israel and all the other countries with
high vaccination rates that still have
kobit coming back wave after wave it's
also unlikely because viral mutation and
animal reservoirs mean that it's going
to keep coming back in different forms
and there's also the possibility that
the vaccines themselves are driving
viral evolution towards vaccine
resistant variants so herd immunity is
not a justification
second vaccine mandates unfortunately do
not protect the vulnerable because the
vaccines as we know don't reliably
prevent infection and transmission so
they lead to a dangerous false sense of
security it's like if you have three
guns and you know one of them is loaded
you have to treat them as if they're all
loaded right and it's the same thing we
can't distinguish between the treatment
of the vaccinated on the unvaccinated
with respect to the potential for spread
because we all can spread the virus
and finally vaccine mandates aren't
necessary to keep hospitals from
overflowing for a lot of reasons chief
among them the fact that there are early
treatment options for covid that can
help to keep people out of the hospital
if they do contract covid19 whether
they're vaccinated or not
so you might be thinking you know who
who are you to make these assertions
right i'm not a doctor i'm not a
scientist and you're right i'm not um
and i don't expect anyone to believe my
conclusions about public health based on
my say so but i am a critical thinker
and so are you and so is everyone in
this room and this is where critical
thinking is really vital i think we all
have a duty to ask probing questions
when our personal health and civil
liberties and societal well-being are at
stake
we have a duty to read and listen beyond
the simplistic messages of the
mainstream media sources and
institutions
and we need to consider the many
intelligent and thoughtful independent
physicians and scientists around the
globe who speak from experience and who
have nothing to gain by their words
except that they want to help humanity
to people who say that we should leave
the thinking to the experts i say that's
balderdash in jury trials we ask lay
jurors to reach million dollar verdicts
all the time in medical malpractice
cases in patent cases we ask laypeople
to evaluate highly complex technical
medical and scientific information
jurors can do it we can do it you can do
it we have to do it this kind of
independent thinking is just too
there's no reason for coercion
discrimination scapegoating and
censorship there's no excuse for
systematically barring people from work
education travel religion and daily life
based on their vaccination status please
do your utmost to set us on a better
course
thank
you
thank you risa any questions for
attorney
evans
not seeing any thank you very much ma'am
if you want to give it to erica there
she'll make sure everyone gets copies of
it
we have nine more
good morning and thank you for the
opportunity to speak
and i and i must say i am wholly
impressed
with all of those folks who've come
before me and who have testified i've
been an advocate for vaccine choice for
well over a decade and i'm really
impressed with how much
research the public has done to inform
themselves and ask thoughtful questions
and make thoughtful decisions you all
should applaud yourselves
my name is laura condon i'm from bedford
i'm a volunteer new hampshire director
of advocacy with the national vaccine
information center
i advocate for voluntary informed
consent for all vaccines
i serve to educate and inform and direct
to resources as are needed
i assist with exemptions and assist with
compliance with viewers reporting
i assist those who have been injured or
have died
claims in the vaccine injury
compensation program
and i have served five years as public
member on the board of directors of the
new hampshire vaccine association
and i understand this committee's charge
was to look at immunization policy as a
whole but certainly there's been a lot
of attention here today to covet and so
i'm going to give a shout out a thank
you to covid and for the coveted
vaccines for finally
bringing the much needed conversation
um to vaccine policy
and what needs to be addressed and what
needs to change
please know that mandates are not a part
of a civilized society
where there is risk
there must be choice
we all know that vaccines are not
without risk
in some of the prior testimony on other
days
there seemed to be considerable
confusion about
vaccine schedules
some people thought it was just a few
vaccines you know maybe three the
children got they didn't get it until
they were four or five years old
i can assure you it's more than three
vaccines
the child vaccine schedule is now up to
72 doses of vaccines between birth and
you can look this up in the cdc website
they will provide you
with the schedules
there is
i don't know how many pages it is what
is it 16 pages
this is the child vaccine schedule
and remember
when you're talking about a shot such as
mmr that's three vaccines in one shot
also what some people are now realizing
there's actually an adult vaccine
schedule as well
which is a new initiative by the federal
government
so now
adults are facing similar mandates to
children
sadly i got this piece of mail
recently
and it refers to the new hampshire
simplified
immunization schedule
this is not the new hampshire simplified
immunization schedule this is the cdc
recommended vaccine schedule
and it is misinformation to represent
that this is the schedule
that that has been approved and required
here in new hampshire
there are
in new hampshire certain requirements on
children
for children in daycare
for children in school
there are 33 doses
of vaccines required
what i'm going to know on both of these
schedules and it's been touched on here
today
is natural immunity
from acquired disease infection in fact
the new hampshire laws and rules provide
for natural immunity for school children
and i will read here from the school
requirements for this coming year
documentation of immunity by confirmed
laboratory tests is acceptable for
measles mumps rubella
varicella and hepatitis b
natural immunity is recognized for those
viral illnesses it is time we recognize
it for
and and on that note
the the testing is for antibodies and i
hope that people will be mindful in
evaluating vaccines to bring them to
market
the measure of
efficacy is based on a measure of
so if antibodies are good enough to
approve a vaccine for advocacy then
certainly they're good enough to
demonstrate
natural acquired immunity
i know that the representative lang one
of the concerns you had mentioned and
the reason for calling for this
committee is the vaccine requirements
imposed on foster families
i testified against those rules
they were not needed rules they were not
required rules by the federal law and i
could not find authority in new
hampshire statute to actually impose
those rules
when i require inquired of a jail car
attorney the statutory authority i was
told to ask dhhs when i asked dhhs their
attorney gave me no response
i could find no statutory authority for
those requirements
in fact what those requirements do and
the question was raised earlier
if those foster family rules for
vaccines require covet shots
indeed they do
they require coveted shots on children
all children at a foster family
household
not just foster children the biological
children who reside there and that is up
to age 21 so that includes 18 year olds
19 year olds and 20 year olds now must
have a covered shot
and i will read from a letter that was
issued by d
the
foster family services september 22nd
from the department
for all children residing in the home
if serving children under the age of six
or any child with
special medical needs
that could mean something simple as
asthma
maybe learning disabilities
all vaccinations as recommended by the
vaccine schedule available on the cdc
website
you might be aware committee members
that the advisor committee and
immunization practices just recently
recommended the coveted shots for
children aged 5 through 11.
that now imposes that mandate on foster
family children
so i hope that addresses that that
then there is a and it should be mindful
too the requirement for foster families
please be aware that foster
parents who lose their children to the
foster system do not lose their parental
rights their rights to make medical
decisions for their children barring a
court order
so any notion that these vaccines simply
could be imposed on these foster
children is wrong
legally wrong
there is and i know that this committee
is charged with looking at all
immunization policy
so i would like you to look at
the
under rsa 141c
these kovichotts
aren't immunizations
i shall read the definition of
immunization from statute
immunization means inoculation
with a specific antigen
to promote antibody formation in the
body
none of the coveted shots contain
antigen
they do not meet the definition of
immunization under new hampshire statute
so there's a number of things to to look
at um and and clean up in law
and again
new hampshire laws should provide for
natural immunity
it is the science
we need to have barefoot verifiable data
from dhhs on disease cases illness and
deaths
individual families must be able to
verify these records we certainly hold a
lot of people accountable for a lot of
things but when i look at
the
cova dashboard and i see here
that dhhs has reported
1597 total deaths to covet there's no
way to verify that
you wouldn't even know if a family
member who passed away was one of those
numbers
there and you might wish to dispute it
there is no way to verify this and audit
it and that is a sorely needed
checks and balance that we need here
to verify that information
because and and quite honestly dhhs has
far less information
on what they report
than the vera system the vaccine adverse
event reporting system
that i know some people
are doubtful about and don't quite
understand
laura i just asked you to kind of wrap
it up a little bit you've done over 10
minutes down because i'm getting to the
bottom of the pile here
um so really this is and and i want
people to be aware the vaccine adverse
event reporting system
is the system that the cdc uses to track
adverse events
the covert vaccine now reports eighteen
thousand seventy eight deaths
fifty seven of those are in new
hampshire
there have been zero child deaths from
coveted reported new hampshire
and two child deaths in new hampshire
as far as the burden on hospitals i know
that some people have talked about the
burden of covet illness in hospitals
please be mindful
that the vaccines the vaccine adverse
reporting system have reported
almost eighty nine thousand
hospitalizations
and nearly ninety six thousand urgent
care visits
so certainly the effects of vaccination
are now without an impact on our health
system
what we should also know in those fears
numbers
one of the the things that was rolled
out in the beginning when um medical
providers were were getting these shots
they were given a system called v safe
it is a cell phone based system where
they will report adverse effects
and i've talked to some of those people
and they said oh sure i reported to
veers it was on my cell phone i said no
you reported to vsafe did you report to
viirs well no i did v-safe so these
numbers reciting from veers don't
include the adverse effects reported to
be safe
so those numbers are
so
in
wrapping up here i want to remind people
that vaccines are not without
risk of failure
and risk of significant harm including
death and i remind you
two children
have died in new hampshire following
coveted vaccination
none ever died from covet itself
vaccines are not hair nets
as you've heard in testimony on another
day
vaccines permanently alter your body
many times not for the better they're
not something you can take off when you
go home from work
vaccines are truly not hair nuts
voluntary
works
we have evidence of that through the new
hampshire vaccine association
76 percent of the budget spent on child
vaccines in new hampshire are for
vaccines that are consumed on a
when shots are free available everywhere
if they are truly
safe and effective
people will line up for them no van no
mandates are needed
and let me wrap up with a reminder where
there is risk there must be choice and i
hope with covid and the coveted vaccines
this will finally move the needle on
that and recognize there should be
choice for all
all vaccines thank you
thank you laura any questions for miss
condon
[Applause]
thank you you're all set laura
so laura i will just give you an update
i filed a petition with hhs to reopen
the foster family
they replied back they're not reopening
that rule because they are not mandating
a coveted vaccine for foster families
that was their interpretation i'll deal
with that later i'm just letting you
thomas mcleod
so we have
a couple added so i think we have nine
more speakers at this point
my goal would be to considering it's 11
30 is just to run through the nine
thank you mr chair thank you members of
the committee
my name is thomas macleod i am the chair
of the liberty defense fund
of new hampshire and i am also
one of the a member of the leadership of
uh health room new hampshire which is a
501 c 4
advocacy organization that's been active
since 2016.
and on a personal note
my family and i moved to new hampshire
from our home in vermont
we saw the writing on the wall and we
understood that
it was a politically unsafe
environment and unsafe environment to be
raising children
with
all kinds of medical mandates
coming down in 2018
my associates and i
hosted a conference on health freedom
where we just invited speakers to talk
about
the issue of
bodily autonomy and the science behind
vaccination
and the
the hostility
and the threats coming from
the media
and
members of the community and this was in
stowe vermont were so extreme
that the conference had to be
that's when i decided i had had enough
so i just want to uh speak briefly about
three subjects our organization has
assisted about 60
employees
with um with their requests for
religious uh accommodation under title
vii of the civil rights act in 1964
and
i had i have to say that
there is tremendous amount of
misinformation
about these exempt so-called exemptions
a lot of it is coming from the employers
themselves
and a lot of it is coming from
various government entities
uh for example uh many employers are
being told if you if you don't have a
letter from your
uh clergy then you can't get an
exemption or if your if your uh
description of your
religious
conviction and the reason you can't take
a vaccine doesn't fit into a three-line
description
on
on a form then you can't get a religious
exact
exemption etc etc
so the um
the cases that i've seen
where
employees have
filed a
fully described
uh
description of their religious beliefs
and how that
impacted their decision to refuse the
vaccine have mostly been granted
it takes a tremendous amount of effort
and research to write one of these
and
and i think that laws would
regulation is in order
to prevent
employers from misinforming employees
so
the universal declaration of bioethics
and human rights
was a
u.n declaration that was put in place in
ratified by
193 countries including the u.s
and
this document defines uh consent at
as being prior free
and informed and it is there to protect
the individual
not the doctor not the medical
researcher
but today in new hampshire as in many
states we have
uh informed consent but the informed
consent is there to protect the
practitioner from liability
or
a medical researcher from charges of
unethical conduct
we need a definition
of informed consent that protects the
bodily autonomy of the individual
not the practitioner and
introduced
attempted to do that
now we're having this committee
to
review
and to define what a medical
intervention is
because we seem to have failed to do
that with the version of hp 220 that
passed
so a working definition
of what a medical intervention is is any
procedure or action that breaks or
passes through the skin
bodily or bodily orifice for the purpose
of
diagnosing testing treatment
or prevention of any disease or medical
condition it's really that simple
so that includes any injection of a
pharmaceutical
any surgery
water fluoridation which is
added added to the water to
prevent dental caries
it does not include
routine vision and hearing tests
a routine
physical for employment or school
it does not include a 24-week ultrasound
does not include a breathalyzer test it
does not include
and there is a gray area having to do
with
uh manipulations uh such as chiropractic
routine chiropractic adjustments
so i i'd like to
[Music]
start with a definition like that
right now just to wrap up right now we
have
virtually no protections
uh for individuals when their informed
consent has been violated
in 2019 a woman
brought her child to a pediatrician in
nashua
and refused a vaccine
they actually
locked the door and prevented her from
leaving
until she signed a an aap waiver
she refused to sign the waiver and she
had to call 9-1-1 in order to be let out
so
where i'm going with that is
if you ask a hospital administrator
do patients have
the absolute right to refuse
a medical treatment a recommendation
and a lot of times you'll get a very
great answer they'll say something like
well it's a it's a group decision uh
well it's it's a decision made by the
team
that's that's really not the question
the question is
does the individual have
the liberty interest does it do they
have the right in and of themselves
to to make that choice
to
refuse
and as we don't have that choice right
now the hospital
makes the choice for us and
and they will
uh very often times uh become coercive
when they when the individual doesn't
make the choice that they want you to
make they don't uh they'll they'll cut
back visitation or they'll prevent you
from calling a lawyer or or they'll make
things difficult for you in many other
ways
so
this is absolutely essential
that informed consent be defined
as an individual right and individual
liberty to protect bodily autonomy
and with that i'll wrap up if there are
any questions
thank you mr mcleod any questions or mr
mcleod
not seeing any we're all set thank you
[Applause]
next up is david i'm gonna
butcher that last name
larue
so while david's coming up i did want to
the goal of this committee was not
necessarily to focus on just
immunizations it was where in state law
we currently have medical interventions
where we have shalls and shall not in
law where the government says you must
do this or the government says you
cannot do that and that could be either
in federal in state law could be in in
state rules is what we're looking to
expand upon here in addition to the
immunization question so house bill 220
which is a bill i've sponsored was the
beginning of this conversation um and it
uh that bill uh banned government from
mandating on a broad basis uh
vaccinations as a condition of
participating in society so as you're
testifying as we're talking again our
goal here was to to look at larger you
know we know there are some places where
medical interventions are warranted i
i'm a former police officer so i use
things like
a suicidal person right there's a reason
for a law enforcement officer make that
person get some mental health care and
put them in into a facility to allow
them to get the treatment they need at
least initially so they're not suicidal
and not walk away from them so there's a
case of medical intervention another
case of i use is corrections right so if
you have a inmate who gets stabbed on in
in the in prison you're not going to
walk away from that inmate while
they need medical care the corrections
is going to get them stitched up so they
don't bleed out on the floor
and then lastly we talk about some
simple things in everyday life things
like someone who's heavily intoxicated
where they may go and put a way to be
dried out or put put it so they don't
have alcohol poisoning as again as a
former police officer it's not uncommon
for me to bring somebody to hospital and
say check their blood make sure they're
not at levels for death
before we go and just take them to the
jail to sober up so again non-uncommon
so we're looking for areas in law around
there and rules that are beyond the
simple immunization um which we've been
talking mostly of today so just as uh if
anybody has goes home and thinks about
things like that if you could uh feel
free to email the committee so we have
that information sorry david didn't mean
to rep you go ahead all right uh my name
is david lebru i am from alexandria and
uh
you know i'd love to talk broad scale
because i think that's really uh
where we're at
we can nickel and dime the minutia of
your evidence versus my evidence your
science versus my science you have a
doctor we have a doctor we can go back
and forth until perpetuity comes okay
that is not the question here the
question is broadly is this right is
this moral is this how our government
should operate
and i've been thinking as i've been
sitting who should i talk to this
committee in this audience as
should i speak as a person who has a
child on the way
should i speak as somebody who's an
off-grid homesteader should i speak to
somebody who is a new hampshire state
certified emt should i speak as somebody
who has done 120 pound body
transformation and used to have
comorbidities should i speak as somebody
who owned a personal training gym who my
business and 300 000
helping people
to become more healthy to avoid all
medical problems
do i speak as somebody who has done
group fitness training who has been a
lifeguard do i speak as a blue-collar
worker who for the first year and some
change of this i drove a garbage truck
and plowed snow
i was the one picking up the dumpsters
full of mass full of this supposed
biohazard we got no incentive pay we got
no hazard pay
we were given no special uh
ppe
who do i speak to you as do i speak to
you as a blue collar joe joe american
that is the question because we all come
from different places but all of us are
covered under the constitution the bill
of rights
all men are created equal we have
recognized that we have had inequities
and we have had minority groups who have
advocated that they were not being
treated fairly just in this room right
there we have multiple signs evidence of
discrimination face covering required
i was so excited because i was able to
actually stop and drink out of the
public water fountain because last time
i went to my newfound school board
meeting i was not allowed to drink from
the public water fountain because it was
are we working towards masked or
unmasked seating for our reps are we
working towards vacs or unvac seating if
these kind of interventions generally
continue to be applied
i spent a month
on the roadside outside of dartmouth
hitchcock in lebanon and i met countless
nurses practitioners l a's
people who work in the hospital in
sanitation in food
all saying the same thing
dartmouth hitchcock health is broadly is
the second largest employer in the state
it's only behind the actual state they
are the largest private employer
and it has grieved my heart and many of
the people that i know i am in this room
with because i have known them and stood
with them since dartmouth hitchcock
health brought out their medical
mandates and it grieves me that these
conversations in action and in a real
spotlight on these issues has only been
brought after it was a red versus blue
federal versus state issue
the time to stand was when the largest
employer in the state made a policy that
said
you will vaccinate
apply for some kind of an exemption
which may or may not be granted and then
when we get done deciding whether or not
your religion is valid
we may or may not fire you and by
signing on to this you have now agreed
to your own termination
please tell me who makes occupational
health the arbiter of your religion in
this country
i have a friend who has had the um
influenza vaccine
as a religious exemption
she was approved by her employer for a
religious exemption for the influenza
vaccine
and then she was denied a religious
exemption
and now no longer works for that
i'd like to read some numbers
okay
i will speak to you as a critical
thinker as joe blow
this is from
covid19.nh.gov
backslash dashboard
i have followed this website
since last march
since it came up march april whenever
this came up when we had less than 200
cases in the state
okay
all of these numbers i recorded off of
this official.gov site when i was
sitting there these are the most current
numbers the actual state will provide us
google states that new hampshire has a
population from the 2019 census of 1.36
million
i've heard it's about 1.4 million i did
some math while i was sitting there
we'll use 1.3 million when i tell you
these numbers so these numbers will
actually be
higher percentages than the truth
in 1.3 million
citizens of new hampshire in 18 months
give or take we have been dealing with
this
we have had 139
324 cases
in 18 months
we have barely had 10.5 the exact number
is 10.71 but as i say this is a little
inflated because i rounded the
population down 10 of new hampshire has
even tested positive in over a year and
a half yet i hear people say we don't
want this to continue forever this is
not a long-term thing this is not about
getting booster shots into perpetuity
this is not about making people test
forever this isn't going to hang around
forever
well how long is it going to take before
enough people have heard immunity or we
have tested or we've beat this dead
horse into submission and the
pharmaceuticals have enough money that
we can no longer continue this
hospitalizations
1.3 million people 18 months
1935.
the total cases is the only percentage i
will read you that does not start with a
zero
one thousand nine hundred thirty five uh
hospitalizations of 1.3 million people
0.14
why do we have hospitals to treat people
that are sick the hospitals are doing
their jobs
i see you
people out of 1.3 million
in 18 months
zero
point here's another zero
0.045 percentage of new hampshire has
been hospitalized with this
zero 0.12
look i'm not a cold person
many of you who have heard me speak
before i get broken to tears because i
am equal parts unhappy with our
government and heartbroken for my nation
this brings me to tears but it is not
lost on me that i have no grandparents
left my father has been dead for years
on 34. it did not take covid or some
miraculous novel virus that is so
contagious that in 18 months we've
barely scratched 10 of the population
okay it did not take any of that for all
of my family members
in that rig regard to already have
passed
of the
1597 deaths
are in long-term care
now objectively let's take the feelings
out of this because we don't legislate
on feelings we don't do medicine on
feelings we do evidence-based medicine
we legislate on what is statistically
significant we make policy of laws not
mandates we legislate and the public
gets comment i will not thank you and
this is not a disrespect but i will not
thank you for being allowed public input
on things that are going to affect us
that is the requirement i will thank you
guys for coming
okay 60 long-term care objectively who
is in long-term care
people who are not just elderly
often elderly but people who are already
sickly for a whole variety of reasons
and objectively closer to death
as i heard it said when the great johnny
cash died when i was in high school that
he had one foot in the grave and the
other on a banana peel that is just a
statistical fact
okay
of the long-term care settings this
website also breakdowns
healthcare workers
we have had 11 healthcare workers die
0.7 percent
of those uh sorry i forgot which number
that was but 11 hospital workers have
died
this has been
thrown everywhere as the hospitals are
so high risk
we need to force all of this stuff in 18
months we've had 11 hospital workers or
long-term care uh people
die
now under 30 because what is coming if
medical interventions are continued to
be pushed as legitimate without proper
informed consent by coercive measures if
these things are continued we will be
talking about children's vaccines maybe
in a few weeks in a few months
under 30 years old
and up until very recently the number
was zero but it shows now from nh.gov or
the the gov website that we have had two
deaths under 30.
it is widely known that almost
everyone
statistically significant has had not
one not two but multiple comorbidities
or has already been somebody who is very
sick who it has
real health problems
now what is the average life expectancy
in new hampshire google says it is 79.4
give or take
we also on this website government data
have an 80 plus category
80 plus
accounts for
59.1
of deaths
better than half and up until a couple
days ago it was over 60
and this 60 to 65 rough number has been
consistent with both long-term care and
age category since last year if you can
find some data from the previous years
those percentages have been very very
similar within a few percentage points
it's pretty much always been about 60 of
people whether we had 200 cases or 139
000.
60 of people are already over the
average life expectancy i have relatives
who are over the average life expectancy
there are people probably people in this
room or in the legislature who are also
over the average life expectancy but if
you are beyond that point what does that
actually mean
really statistically
it means you are less likely to survive
the day than you are from anything cove
under 30 i didn't read you the
percentage keep track count on your
fingers
0.00015
percentage of our deaths in this state
in 18 months have been people under the
i'm going to finish with this my own
quote
it was said earlier about these great
photographs and our forefathers and how
the government is supposed to operate
be a man and a person and a legislator
and a leader that our forefathers would
not have been ashamed to stand in a room
with
thank you david
next up is jay island
jay
well i wanted to ask are you uh
are you folks planning are you certainly
going to have
one or two more
of these hearings this week
there will be a second public
information session or input session on
wednesday um depending on who shows up
we'll either move into having a
discussion about what we've heard or
we'll hear testimony from people that
show up
okay so
if say only i showed up you would have a
second session
we're gonna have the second session no
matter what it just depends whether
there's anybody there to speak yep
okay
now my second question is
would i be permitted to make a statement
now
on a certain aspect of this issue and
then make a second one
sure
okay
i am going to speak
you have just heard from david larue
that
there's an absurdity in the air he
didn't say that precisely himself but
you could feel it in what he was saying
that there is a sense of an intense
orwellian
absurdity in the air around this issue
and it's because of the types of things
that david was describing
that are taking place everywhere all
now why is this
uh while i'm on the subject of the globe
i might as well mention global
financiers
and uh rather than this being this this
favorite um kind of weaponized uh term
conspiracy theory
this is not a conspiracy theory
mr
bill gates
is one of those financiers big time
and bill gates has everything to do
with this vaccination program with the
entire covid
uh deception
that is taking place
globally
and this is shameful it is shameful that
the united states
would become
a nation of censorship
over an issue like this
what have we become
george orwell wrote his novels
not as fantasy stories even the novel
animal farm was not really a fantasy
story at all
his novel
was a precise manual for stalinism
it was a precise down to the detail
description of how stalinism works and
what do we see today
over the covet issue
but this is stalinism it's imported
directly partially through the red
chinese system
we see
the red shine it's it's really the red
chinese uh what do you call it social
credit system that's being enacted
and we're seeing red chinese purges
being enacted
excuse me sir
i apologize for interrupt can i just
have you know just step up to the mic
someone online just said they can't hear
what you're saying because you're not
near the mic
this is actually a gigantic red chinese
purge and it's a red chinese style i
mean i
i should say style
um
cultural revolution what happened in the
red chinese cultural revolution
but
an entire
legacy of history an entire legacy of
religions
was totally demolished
we're seeing our culture in the of the
united states being demolished just the
same
and i would like to to uh thank god
himself that we're able to still
have a setting here such as we see right
now today where
citizens still can
physically stand up and speak
to folks like you on a committee
i thank god for this because we are
getting close we are getting very close
to the point where this will not even be
something
and
and okay
general stark
is the author
yeah okay so the general star so sir
they need you to speak into the
microphone because the online people can
that are watching this remotely can hear
what you're saying
okay
i i i just assumed because of the very
poor uh speaker system in this room that
it would be better at a distance okay
general stark
is the author of the new hampshire motto
which is live free or die and many
people don't know that general stark
also mentioned
when he said that
that there are things that are worse
than death or sickness or that sort of
thing
he mentioned that there are things that
are much worse
and what we're seeing taking place as a
result of this coveted global nonsense
is something that is much worse than
death
our forefathers
fought and died
for the principles that are being
absolutely trashed
in the state of new hampshire and in the
united states of america
trashed
over a little bug that's supposed to get
us all
scared and benjamin franklin is reputed
to have said uh it's not actually
written down in his writings but he's
reputed to have said to a lot of his
friends that those who
would sacrifice
those who would trade away
their god-given rights
for
temporary
deserve neither and will receive
neither liberty nor safety
so
general george washington was mentioned
when he inoculated his troops he was
acting as a military officer the the the
highest military officer in the military
people sacrifice their rights
temporarily
so that they may become a legitimate uh
functioning engine that can protect
their nation so that their rights
may be preserved
so that the rights of everybody else may
be preserved and so to compare his
inoculation of troops seems rather inept
to me
and then
uh what are mandates well
mandates are either
fascism or they are direct
uh
decrees
from someone who's put themselves up as
kind of a sat drought a kind of a a
regional dictator or perhaps they're the
president of the united states
setting himself up in the same way
or
the mandates are being done through
fascism if you look at a
dictionary and you find a really good
definition of fascism you'll find out
that fascism
partnerships and in a public private
private partnership kind of atmosphere
you can very easily use money in
all kinds of a multitude of ways in
order to have the money come down from
above
and to
uh
have strings attached that are like
gigantic steel cables
forcing the situation and that's exactly
what we see happening now this is
fascism and for people who think that
fascism is on the extreme right nothing
doing
the extreme left is government
controlling everybody the extreme right
is is the those
those people who think that there
shouldn't be any kind of government at
all
so so fascism may be a few tiny degrees
to the right or maybe to the left of
communism but it certainly is not on the
right of the political spectrum
so here we see what's going on and it
you're going on 13 minutes
okay we see fraud taking place which is
fraud and absolute absurdity an example
of the fraud
that fauci has committed
is that he claimed
he claimed that rem deserver
and and this is
this is ensconced
in the very coveted protocol treatment
that is still being used right now fauci
is a fraud he claimed
that rem deserver was a highly
successful treatment
for ebola and therefore it should be
used for coven 19 disease
well the fact is that the study that he
based that on
in that study
of the people treated with rem deservier
died it was by far the largest
percentage in that study of people who
died
and of course ebola is a strong disease
too and i take that into consideration
but
fauci used that it's a direct flat out
blunt bald-faced lie that fauci
told in his covid protocol and that
protocol is the very one that is being
used right now and it's being mandated
so so we get it
again back to the subject of mandates
what are mandates
i have a sign that i made that says
mandates are lawless decrees because
that's exactly what they are
they have no nothing constitutional
behind them and in fact those who
cooperate
with this are violating the constitution
the highest law of the land both of the
us and new hampshire
so that's about all i have to say for
today thank you so much thank you people
for giving real time
thank you god thank you
[Applause]
thank you
next stop is kelly potanza potenza is
so i had the same question that he had
so about wednesday because
i wanted to actually hear what everybody
said first before i spoke
so i'm actually going to speak on
wednesday but i just would like to say
one thing here about house bill 220 and
tim i know you know who i am because
i've uh have many conversations with you
about this
so when house bill 220 was first you
know originally initiated
it actually had protections right
so
you know i just want to read it
because this is what
this is where it should ended
every person
has the natural essential and inherent
right to bodily integrity free from any
threat or compulsion
by government to accept an immunization
end of story
there should have been nothing else
added to this
and instead we had legislatures
that decided to take it on their own
to add conditions on there
and
there's so much that i can unpack just
with hp 220
because it's very similar in a sense
to let's say the biden mandate
right so we have the buy to mandate
where everyone you know is gonna you
know all these businesses over a hundred
employees all of the stuff right they
have to all get an injection
except for the people that work in the
white house or the post office or
whatever
in
in new hampshire
we did the same
in a sense right because this didn't
protect any any private individual it
didn't protect my rights or my job or
anything like that didn't protect all of
these healthcare workers that were
heroes forever
until okay we have a mandate now
but here in the state
it protects everybody that's in this
building working in here that gentleman
that dictator that's in the corner
office protects him protects all state
employees
doesn't protect any of these people that
are probably sitting here right now
and that's what
that's why everything is is is all smoke
and mirrors
and that's been the problem all along
people were championing you along were
championing this tim you were
championing this and when you first put
this out it was fantastic but it got
gutted in the senate
not by the democrats by the people that
we had the majority
and everybody needs to know that the
people that are supposed to be on the
side of freedom my freedoms to protect
my freedoms right constitutional rights
that didn't happen
so i've got a lot more to say next time
around but i just wanted to uh uh i
don't want to thank
i don't i don't think we should have to
thank we should be here all the time
speaking about this
but to be honest none of this should be
even happening anyway you have zero
constitutional authority at all based
upon new hampshire constitution to tell
me what i can do or not do with my body
my body by my choice only applies to
killing babies
give me a break i'm really done with all
of this but thanks for being here and i
thank you kelly
dora
doris
i am a
born again
christian
and when this whole thing started the
masking i i said
i've taken off my mask i can't put it
how do i
how do i god that would hang on the
cross
for our sins
the father that would give his son
who's pleading with us right now
and we're
we're doing everything but opening that
book and reading it and i'm gonna make
this
quick if
if my people which are called by my name
shall humble themselves and pray and
seek my face and turn from their wicked
ways
then will i hear from heaven and will
forgive their sin
and will heal their land it's a sin
virus it's a hundred percent deadly
i've got this one last thing i'll add
the clock
the clock of life is wound but once
and no man has the power
to tell just when the hands will stop at
late or early hour
to lose one's wealth is sad indeed
to lose one's health is more
to lose one's soul is such a loss
that no one can restore
our eternal souls are at stake
choose choose this day who you serve
thank you lord
[Applause]
desiree
londington
we're coming down with the last we have
seven more speakers so
winding down here go ahead mim um so i
just want to speak from a
personal person step up to the michael
there you go i just want to speak about
um with my personal experience with the
covent
whatever you want to call it
i have
i am personally someone
who
worked in
a hospital setting a
um
part of dhmc
and i am the one well one of the few
that david talked about that had a
religious exemption for the flu vaccine
for four years
prior to coven 19.
i am also
somebody
who wore
ppe multiple times
and was told not
to even wash it
not even to wipe it clean to go into
room to room to room to room
using the same contaminated ppe
i
worked in environmental services
there are regulations of
properly
labeling rooms so that we know how to
clean them
that we know
what ppe to put on to go in there to
keep ourselves safe
every day every day i went to work i
stepped in a room
that was a coven 19 positive case
i have not gotten sick
i have not
taken i've not been tested
because
in my religious belief
i do not take unnecessary medical
procedures
it is unnecessary for me to take
i had to be out i chose to be out of
work for 10 days
because i wouldn't be tested
that is the only time during this whole
pandemic
if that's what you want to call it that
when
this vaccine came out
at first
it
you didn't have to get it they didn't
care
but then they said everybody had to have
it but you can apply for a religious or
medical exemption
so i did i know my constitutional rights
and i was not going to
fill out the outrageous
forms that they put i was not going to
agree to wear extra ppe that i had
almost passed out from wearing cleaning
so i was denied my religious exemption
because i would not adhere
to
their policy
i resigned i wasn't fired i resigned
because i was one of four people at this
hospital
that could properly clean coven 19 rooms
or the operating room
i saw daily people who were vaccinated
coming to work
sick
coughing fevers shaking no matter if
this covid thing wasn't even here those
people should not have been at work
i saw this with my own eyes
i was there
um
and that's my testimony personally
i also have a daughter
who
is 13 that comes to a lot of events with
me so some of you might have seen her
she actually had a reaction to her mmr
vaccine
i was told when she was i think she was
five or six at the time
i was told
when i called because my daughter was
limp
fever
so hot i could barely touch her i felt
like my hands were gonna burn
i thought my daughter was going to die
i was told by a nurse
at the hospital
that i could bring her into the
emergency room
but there wasn't anything that they
could do
so i decided to keep my daughter home
because if she was going to die she was
that
record has not even been put in her
medical records
the hospital did not
report that to theirs
or anywhere that she had that reaction
also with the same daughter
so it is very hard for her to do things
she has been told and i have emails that
i can forward
but i don't have them on me because i
didn't know what i didn't even know that
that
she would not be able to participate in
gym class
if she did not wear a mask
they would bench her from getting
physical activity in school
because she has a hard time breathing
and doing physical activities with a
mask on
this daughter because she wants to see
her friends
and be social with her friends
puts a mask on her face when she goes to
school
and when she comes home
you can tell that she hasn't had the
she had
she has allergies
and
[Music]
when she's active which she only goes to
school for two classes because we
her temperature
rises it's
it's been told to me since she was
i don't know three
um the doctors have written many school
nurses saying unless she has
a fever over 100.5 not to worry about it
it's just how her body works
she recently had to be pulled out of her
classes
because she had a temperature of
99.6
after gym class
and because she has allergies
and
was upset that she was put in
an isolation room that's her words
an isolation room in the nurse's office
she was having a panic attack because
all alone
when nobody else
and nobody even called me
nobody told me that she was put in this
room they said she had a sniffle and a
fever but nobody told me that
she was isolated
so she was out of school for 10 days and
none of those 10 days was she given any
of her schoolwork how is that right
how is that okay
for her to fall behind and have to make
all that up
because of something that most likely
again we don't test
so we're not sure but she wasn't sick
there is no exemptions nothing for
children at school for sports
so
she won't be able to play basketball
again this year even though she wants to
because
it's required to wear a mask inside but
not outside and you can
basically kiss your friend outside
but inside you have to socially distance
and have a mask on
[Music]
also i wanted to say that
i did work at a hospital so there is
vaccines that we had to
have
immune to certain
certain diseases
so when i started there
they couldn't find my hepatitis b
vaccine
so i had to have my titers
taken
even though i had had my hepatitis b
vaccine
i'm not immune to hepatitis b
so
because they didn't protect me from
hepatitis b
i'm not immune to hepatitis b
so why why this whole push for vaccines
that
aren't even going to work that
that natural immunity is most likely
better
and i'll close with this
because what's coming here
i read just last week
on the second from the wall street
journal
because i lost my job so i had to take
five dollar pay cut and now i work at a
such that china penned in 30 000
people
in a park
because of one
covid
19 case one
that's what's coming here
if we don't stop it and we stop it now
that's what's coming here we will be
pending
if somebody here had proven 19 we would
if china comes here if we let china come
here
so please don't
all of you
thank you desiree thank you next up is
claudine burnt
burnham
hello my name is claudia mirnum and i'm
from milton new hampshire
i wasn't prepared to speak but after
hearing a few things i've been inspired
so i want to share you something that's
very
personal to me in my family
and
maybe this might resonate
so as a mother of four daughters
i trusted my pediatricians and nurses
however when i questioned them the need
and the safety of the vaccines my babies
received
they began to show me laminated pictures
of sick
rashy
and even dead babies
they also told me that if i did not have
my children could not return to the
office
i felt belittled and bullied
i did what most mothers do
which was to listen to the doctors
and continue with the scheduled
immunizations
so as time went on my oldest healthy
daughter
was diagnosed with scoliosis
which later led to
uncomfortable bracing
doctor's appointments
x-rays
and eventually to a spinal fusion
surgery
where she received two 14 inch titanium
rods
and 19 screws
screwed to her spine
after a painful bone graft from her hip
to cover her spine
for bone regrowth needed
to cover these rods
she underwent a nine hour surgery
where she also needed a blood
transfusion as well
all the specialists told me
there were no reasons for scoliosis
no studies that can show why this
happens
and they also said this wasn't proven to
be genetic
which was very confusing because we
didn't have this in either side
of her family
yet for some reason three
of my four daughters
all suffer from scoliosis
so last year being homebound due to the
lockdown
i did some serious research
and discovered
the very few studies that have been done
on scoliosis
but one study
related to this spine disease has
similarities to polio
however
due to the lack of
funding
as we heard this morning children have
received 72 vaccines
that's a minimum
as a child i probably received five
including polio
i'm not sure if any of these vaccines
caused my daughter's scoliosis
but there does seem to lie some
suspicion
what happens to the people's bodies
through generational vaccines
do we know
are there any studies
i haven't found any
if we don't even know how the long-term
safety and effectiveness of our current
immunizations
how can we continue
to mandate any experimental
and approved vaccines
thank you claudine
[Applause]
shannon
how you doing i'm gonna be reading for
my phone and i'd just like to make this
statement that
the statement i'm making reflects only
my personal beliefs and it does not
reflect that of my job currently
my name is shannon gardner and i live in
epsom new hampshire
i've been a first responder all my life
and also live in a dual household the
first responders
myself my boyfriend
pretty much my boyfriend and myself have
driven every emergency vehicle equipped
with red white and blue lights
i serve several years in the military
and i also come from a family of nursing
police and teachers
all my life i have taken positions to
defend the freedoms of others and will
continue to do so today
the topic of patriotism was brought up
before and i think the true definition
of patriotism is signing your life away
in a dotted line for your country and
not taking a vaccine
when i was younger
still in the military i was going to
thailand to teach english
and i was told i needed a special
vaccine
i got the japanese encephalitis vaccine
because i was told i had to get it or i
couldn't go
i agreed and got the shot
as i stood up to walk away after rolling
down my sleeve i was told to sit down
and wait
when i asked why i couldn't leave
i was told it was because the vaccine
was new and my branch for the military
still didn't know all the fold side
side effects so they would have to
monitor me for an additional 30 minutes
to make sure i didn't have any immediate
side effects
now that i'm older
with additional education
additional life experience and also out
of the military
i don't want to be another test subject
i also refuse to see my two step kids
two beautiful little girls
or any other child be the nation's
guinea pig to an experimental vaccine or
booster shot
mandating vaccination for work or being
forced to show proof of vaccination as
medical tyranny
thank you for your time
thank you very much
good morning
can i just get your last name
axelman a-x-e-l-m-a-m thank you my name
is elliot axelman i'm a critical care
and flight certified paramedic i've been
in ems since 2011 so that's about 10
years
overall the education for whoever cares
about education it's for paramedic and
all the emt and all that stuff is about
roughly the same as a pa a physician
assistant so it's a few years
and uh like 600 hours of clinicals
i've worked in i've worked in uh
critical care transfers and 911 systems
throughout new york and throughout new
hampshire now for the past few years
all of my experience and all the data
that i've seen because i've researched
covent i
actually worked in a coveted hospital
last year in may of 2020 i worked for a
few weeks in atlanta in a hospital with
just covet patients for overflow from
grady hospital
all my experience with covet and the
data and research of the statistics
leads me to believe
that the stats of
cases
infectiousness lethality
and uh just how dangerous it is in
general have been exaggerated like
nothing in history of existence
depending on exactly the figures looking
at it might have been exaggerated by a
hundred fold maybe a thousand fold maybe
ten thousand fold
they inflated the statistics from the
beginning in order to propagandize the
entire pandemic as we know now and in
order to pass
the
you know millions of different forms of
corona fascism including in new
hampshire and throughout the world they
inflated statistics first by cycling the
pcr tests 40 45 times instead of 20 25
times which was the standard and that
might have caused i don't know 99.9
false positives maybe so right right
there we have maybe an inflation of a
million fold of statistics they also
bribed hospitals as we know now cms the
center for medicaid and medicare
services the federal government that
sets all the reimbursement rates and
they pay almost every person is a
medicaid or medicare payer maybe 70 80
90 of patients in the united states have
medicaid or medicare so they control the
rates as well and they have most
patients they were reimbursing hospitals
i think uh nine thousand or thirteen
thousand dollars per covenant admission
and thirty seven thousand dollars per
ventilator use if you listed covid so
again when you incentivize people with
money they're more likely to do it it's
very simple
that also might have inflated statistics
by again who knows how much 10 50 100 a
thousand fold because they're giving
them 37 thousand dollars per patient but
it gets even crazier a lot crazier they
started saying we don't even need tests
anymore there's something called
pathonemonic in medicine pathomonic
means a symptom that is a rare symptom
and it's guaranteed 100 of certain
disease they made it seem like every
symptom from general symptoms like
weakness fever rapid heart rate slow
heart rate rapid breathing slow
breathing uh tiredness nausea diarrhea
very common symptoms that everyone has
from time to time they essentially said
the cdc that all of those symptoms each
of them is pathomonic for covid meaning
if someone has weakness or a headache or
a rapid heart rate we are 100 sure they
have covid you don't even have to test
them why waste a test i'm 100 sure they
have coveted so if anyone in a hospital
has a heart rate over 100 which i in my
opinion maybe 99 of patients in the
hospitals have a rapid heart rate at
some point we can say 100 it's 100 sure
it's covered let's let's covet again
that inflated statistics by
essentially calling everyone coveted so
right there we have
statistics that could essentially say
that every human in the hospital in the
world has coveted because everyone in
the hospital by definition has some
symptom right that it's a place with
sick people so right from the get-go the
statistics were off and again i trusted
medicine i'm a critical thinker as you
guys know me but i also trusted medicine
i trusted the cdc i trusted the fda a
lot more than the other folks in dc but
over the past two years i've lost a lot
of faith and the cdc fda fauci have lost
my faith by doing things that were
anti-scientific
from a year or two ago when they start
started denying for the first time in
history that natural immunity from prior
infection existed when i heard fauci
tell rand paul and house and senate
repeatedly natural immunity that's not
worth nothing you need the vaccine and i
said you know it's got to be worth
something if you have the infection you
have antibodies do it that's how every
virus and bacteria in the universe you
know that's how it works i believe so
right away i knew
so let's stick to the policy let's try
not to assign assign blame
right overall with vaccines i thought
this was about what is considered a
medical intervention i would consider a
vaccine a medical intervention i don't
think there's a lot of debate about that
i think it's important for everyone to
remember again me as a medical provider
who does things to patients very similar
to what an er doctor might do as far as
emergency care we deliver medications
and advanced airways and we run codes
and all that every time i do an
intervention for a patient whether it's
starting an iv and giving them fluid or
medication or defibrillating them or
intubating them with the tube and
putting them on a ventilator before i do
every single thing
i subconsciously or consciously
calculate the risk and reward and just
two things there's what is the what is
the risk percentage and how profound is
that risk is it a 80 risk and is the
risk very profound is it death or is it
a low risk and a low amount of you know
not a very bad side effect and the same
with the benefit what's the chance of
benefit if i give an asthmatic albuterol
the benefit might be 80 and the benefit
is tremendous benefit because it can
help them with these vaccines and the
big takeaway is
overall what's the benefit of the
vaccine that depends on how bad covet is
again at all my experience it's not a
pandemic there are millions of reasons
why the overall death rate if you look
at mortality has not gone up it's steady
2018 2019 20 20 21 there's no
significant increase meaning people who
may have died of flu or other causes as
someone mentioned they were 80 years old
meaning they were technically speaking
the the most likely to die and the
insult would have killed them it could
have been a flu or a trip and fall which
we see a lot with elderly or coronavirus
so if the overall excess mortality rate
is not going up then by definition it's
not necessarily a pandemic
overall what's the benefit of the
vaccine again we have a lot of people
throughout the united states believing
what they see on tv and from dc
politicians saying everyone has to get
the vaccine that's going to save you
even though at the same time they're
saying it's you could still get it and
you can still transmit it even with the
vaccine
the benefit is directly proportional is
related to how bad covet is for instance
me i'm 28 i'm in excellent shape i'm a
boxer runner power lifter a personal
trainer so i'm a decent shape the risk
of me getting covered and dying from it
is very very small i don't know maybe
one in a million one in a billion so
that's that risk now let's compare it to
the rest of the vaccine i don't know
what it is but maybe not one in a
million maybe one in a thousand of
myocarditis
kind of small but kind of big a lot
bigger than covet what's the risk of
infertility i'm still trying to have my
first baby my wife and i we're getting
up there in age we're
just about 30 and if we are trying to
have a baby and there's fertility issues
with which a lot of people have
mentioned for a man and female there's
fertility issues for both with the
vaccine we don't know that yet because
it hasn't been studied for that long the
one attending physician in the er i go
to said she's not sure but she waited
until she was totally done having kids
and totally done nursing kids before
getting the vaccine so we just don't
know
when faushi and the dc politicians
started saying we believe pregnant women
should get it based on this and this is
a quote he said we see no reason why it
would have a negative effect on
pregnancy so just get it
that's not again that's not science
that's not really how it works
that's a few more thoughts here
even if this were the approaching ten
minutes just to let you know oh wow
sorry i'll speed up even if this were
the worst pandemic in history like the
bubonic plague multiplied by the spanish
flu and it were killing seven billion
people in the world and we mentioned the
stats here like two people under 30 have
died in new hampshire a total of a
thousand or 1500 have died even if it
were killing billions of people a day i
still as a voluntarist i would not
support any government mandate good
ideas don't require force if it were
killing billions of people would it be
if everyone in the world died and i were
the last person still i wouldn't support
on principle a government mandating what
you put in your body once the government
can mandate what you put in your body
you have no freedom left and as liver
disease state then there's no point in
really living anymore if you can't be
free i went over the very statistics and
others have gone over that a lot so you
don't even have to
and the of course the hygiene hypothesis
the whole hypothesis of the more you're
exposed to things it could be good we
have tons of doctors on record
pediatricians saying maybe we're using
too much bacterial soap and sanitizer
maybe kids should actually be more
exposed to these things and again
speaking of kids they are less
uh vulnerable to kovid than they are the
flu i wrote a whole book about this so i
went over the stats the flu kills more
than covet so kids are more likely to
get the flu and spread the flu and die
of the flu than covet they're a little
more safe with kovid now that kovat
boxed out the flu kids are literally
safer now than they were two years ago
so we should not be masking kids and
abusing kids by making them depressed
and suicidal and on drugs and
not be able to see their friends and not
develop mentally because they can't see
their faces we should take the masks off
masks literally scientifically there's
more reason for to mask kids with flu
in conclusion because pretty much all
corona fascism has arisen from the
government and what the government can't
do and i think a lot of people know this
now the government can't mandate every
single person get a vaccine so they
deputize private companies to do their
dirty work which is disgusting and i
think people are catching on people are
smarter than politicians giving credit
for
my company for instance is has been
deputized either
on purpose or or you know subconsciously
deputized by the government to implement
these mandates and then the government
can say it's not them in fact the
government could say we don't want to
get involved in private business again
we've spoken to sununu about this and
they have been involved in private
business private businesses in new
hampshire especially health like i work
in
have to obey millions of laws i know
there are a total of millions of
regulations so they are already
essentially part of the government so
the government can and should protect us
from the coronal fascism from the
mandates and again someone mentioned the
exemption forms and i will i recall i'll
be emailing you a bunch of exception
forms my company and a lot of other
companies it is four pages for religious
or medical they want you to prove that
your religion is legitimate who's to say
that first amendment anyone prove it's
legitimate and prove that you are a
pious believer in religion and it's
really rigorous and the medical one that
i asked for is four pages they say have
you ever gotten a vaccine before what
was it why did you get it tell me
everything about the vaccine why did you
get that but you don't want to get this
one and it's four pages of tremendously
unethical private hipaa violating
medical history that's extremely
inappropriate i'm sure it's illegal
under numerous federal and state laws so
we'll look into that and you know
ridiculous medical exemption forms so so
the fact that you're that government new
hampshire and the feds are utilizing
private businesses they're deputizing
them to do your dirty work it's pretty
disgusting
in conclusion because pretty much
everything is coming from the feds
either
um directly or indirectly via federal
money the grants the coercion the
propaganda we see the tremendous biggest
propaganda campaign in history of
existence i'm asking every state
representative to support full-on
independence from the union that is the
only thing we can do to get away from
poutine biden we can't ask them nice
theory petitions we need full
independence so i'm asking you all to
support it thank you
thank you elliot appreciate it
guys
we're down to our last two speakers
or at least last two cards i have so um
and two people have left have asked for
a significant amount of time i'm gonna
ask you to try to keep your your your uh
comments to 10 minutes where we've been
trying to keep everybody at not to
exceed 10 minutes um and we'll have next
up howard chase if he's here
hello i'm howard chase i'm a registered
nurse i have been for 47 years
i graduated from new hampshire hospital
school of nursing in
1974.
um
i have a couple of points to make that
are different
is that better okay
first of all
this is all in mandates um
the mandates were originally predicated
under the thought
that those who were not vaccinated
were more likely to spread the vaccine
the the
covet
which of course wasn't true but anyway
that's that's what they said
the cdc said that so it must be right
um
but
uh
i don't think anybody really believed
that if you look at the nih website
they say that the covet germ
or virus
lives on a hard surface for up to three
hours
that means
anybody
can spread the virus whether they're
vaccinated or whether they're not
vaccinated
the cdc stuck to that until july 27 of
this year
on their website
if you go look at the cdc.gov website
they had
information that they put out on the
27th
which stated
and they were only talking about the
variants
but it really clearly applies to any
virus
that
a vaccinated person can
spread
the covert virus
now that was a break from their previous
statements this was on the 27th
as well as people were not vaccinated
the only caveat they had
was to say they
think
they can't do it as long
perhaps
but
if it's three hours it's three hours and
a
person who has not been vaccinated would
be four hours well that's
it doesn't make any sense
so
a lot of
employers have gone to the point of
instead of saying oh well let's see the
unvaccinated they say well the young
vaccine are more likely to be sick so
we'll just get rid of them
that's the latest thing oh they're
they're more sick well the fact is that
now as we all know
the vaccinator getting very sick with
the variants
i have a person very close to me
got
coveted
she was fully vaccinated
she went home to her husband
who was fully vaccinated
they were both very sick
neither one could go to bed they had to
sit up in bed or they had to lie on
their stomach to breathe they had a 12
year old daughter who got
a little sniffle
and we know that's the way it works
so the fact is
it's fraudulent and we know it's
fraudulent so what should be done
is that people who have been fired
because of this should be given their
jobs back
and they should be given back pay
i don't know there's any law that they
care can take care of that but the fact
is this is what should happen this is
fraudulent it's totally political has
the next point
i would like to talk about
is autopsies
now unfortunately and i don't know the
reason i've heard
uh ideas
why
in the united states they just basically
don't allow autopsies on people who have
coded
i could be wrong but it's very difficult
to find information on that however
in other countries it's very simple in
fact in canada
they have some really good studies on
autopsies
by the way i have links for all this
i've sent emails to all five of you
before i came here just in case
[Music]
i didn't have a printer so i could send
you some emails so it's there all of the
links to all of these things are there
don't believe me don't whatever you do
don't believe me do your own research
check it out make sure that there's a
lot of stuff on the internet that
doesn't make any sense
make sure you check out those those
links to find the actual truth
so
in canada they researched the autopsies
they found
unlike what was originally thought
was that that little jab stayed in your
arm and didn't go anywhere else
and then these protein spikes
would create you know
your antibodies and they wouldn't go
anywhere
well
in autopsy they have found that these
protein spikes go throughout the entire
body and bloodstream and even pass
through the blood brain barrier
so what that means is you have little
coveted spikes in your brain
in your ovaries
in your liver in your kidneys
et cetera et cetera et cetera
so that brings us to
well some of the other people have
mentioned that they know
women who stopped ovulating after they
had this well
maybe that's why
can we prove it no because they're not
going to do a study on it because they
don't want us to know that
so
think about this we're talking about
vaccinating kids now
do you really want your five or
six-year-old daughter
to have that covet spike in her ovary
do you want grandchildren
do you not care oh it's better if she
lives it doesn't have children well
let's think about this
what are we doing to ourselves we don't
know
we won't know for 10 years
because it's going to take that long for
us to figure out what's happening to
these kids we know it's happening in
adults we know their ovaries are
stopping to work sometimes they start up
again
again there's not a lot of studies i
just know people who say this is what
happened like the people who previously
testified
so
how can we possibly consider
knowing
like everyone else testified
that these children aren't going to get
sick anyway
but
maybe we'll just sterilize them
or you know
maybe we'll have their kidneys shut down
we know
we know for a fact that there are a lot
of younger people
getting myocarditis and pericarditis
just like the doctor testified earlier
we know that's happening and that's
because those proteins are going to the
heart
and the pericardium sac around the heart
so
why and why especially for young kids
yeah
i'm old i'm 70 years old so what i got
you know
it's probably better because covert
would kill me except i think i already
got it so
that's another story
so
in summary two minute warning
yeah
i guess i can kind of cut it out there
because you've heard enough statistics
on who's dying and there's been a lot of
12 to 17 year olds who've been
significantly significantly affected and
that's in the statistics so i don't need
to tell you about that i sent that to
you in an email
so i'll cut out now so someone else can
follow up thank you
frank staples
my name is frank staples and i came here
today
even though my bail conditions say i
have to stay a thousand feet from the
governor and the executive council when
i came in here that officer said
you're not supposed to be here are you
i said is the governor here hold on this
is all tied in and you will hear don't
stop me and tell me what to say it's my
minutes
my speech
okay
stop
frank
i'm speaking now you're you're you're
wasting my time
so stop frank i'm not wasting your time
but you are sir so i'm gonna continue on
with my first amendment rights
so
i've exercised my first amendment rights
on this issue
since day one
of the lockdowns i've been arrested five
times
and i've been ticketed twice for my
speech
and i will not stop and you cannot stop
me
okay
so
this officer said you're not supposed to
be here and the governor is not here so
he said you're fine the governor's not
here
now the governor's supposedly coming
back and that officer is out there going
to bat for me saying that i shouldn't be
arrested if he does come back and if he
does come back it's entrapment at this
point and i'm not worried about it i
will fight it in court and i will win
so
we also need to have a second shift
meeting or hearing here
for the first shift workers
and or
another one on the weekends to allow the
people who i'm here to represent
to speak their first amendment
if you don't know your rights you don't
have any thank you
hey i am speaking and i'm the chairman
i'm going to ask you to do something if
you want to be heard you are going to
figure it out at the end okay i am
getting to it let me get to my notes
frank
my comment
my comment is that people online can't
hear you because you're screaming in the
mic if you want to be heard put the mic
back on the stand
slow down stop slowly interrupting me
and get impressive with me because i
have ptsd and head trauma and when you
get aggressive with me i get aggressive
and i cannot control the volume of my
voice i am disabled
i cannot control the volume my voice
when i get excited and you are exciting
me and inciting me okay okay so i'm
gonna continue on one more time the
people cannot understand what you're
saying online because you're screaming
into the microphone
i'd ask you to please just i'm not
trying to be rude and interrupt you i'm
just trying to make it so people can
hear you your time is reset when i'm
talking so you're not losing any of your
10 minutes
so i just asked you just please speak
clearly speak to the policy and not the
people clearly and i'm trying to speak
to the policy but you keep interrupting
you sir
okay
how do you know that i know my rights
because i successfully prosecuted this
state
in federal court for violent prisoner
and now you
guys want to experiment on prisoners
with this vaccine
because it is an experiment
i'll read this from fda.gov
overall risk benefit conclusions
let's see here
the number of participants
in
the current clinical development program
is too small to detect any potential
risks of myocarditis associated with
vaccination long-term safety of covid19
vaccine in participants from five to 12
years of age will be studied in five
post-authorization safety studies
including a five-year follow-up to study
and evaluate long-term sequelae of
post-vaccination myomyocarditis
pericarditis
anyone who gets this shot i have friends
who've gotten it and signed the uh
waiver
if you've read the waiver you will know
that you are entering into an experiment
and this is 100 against nuremberg code
and against the constitution's state and
federal
hey frank i'm just gonna say and you're
getting loud and people again are it's
breaking up online so people i don't
care about the people online they can
come here and speak with their feet like
i am like i said i can't control the
volume of my voice when i get excited i
am pissed off and this all ends when
everybody else gets as pissed off
any
end of story i don't care about the
stop
you're making me lose my train of
thought
governor sununu's answer since day one
has been the vaccine the vaccine the
vaccine
but the vaccine as we've heard does not
stop the spread
but the unvaccinated people that are at
work that won't get it have to get
testing why aren't we testing the
vaccinated people as well they should be
tested if anybody is getting tested
because they'd be the asymptomatic
spreaders
all right
so yeah experimenting on prisoners you
guys now want to experiment on prisoners
with this house bill 220 the department
of corrections may mandate medical
treatment or immunization for inmates
when a direct threat exists what direct
threat
i'm supposed to have been dead 10 times
over by attending all these rallies and
hugging people
it's all
bogus and you guys know it it's all
about money have you received pfizer
donations or any other donations from
any of these uh vaccine companies
because the governor has
have you
the nazis
called the jews unclean
and dirty
and they put them in camps
and experimented on them too
just like that 27 million in funding was
going to go to putting me and others
like me
in fema camps isolation and quarantine
upon the orders of the federal
government and you're telling me that
isn't strings attached and that's not
abrogating our state constitutional
rights
and here's a simile for you
everybody talks about spreading kovitz
spreading kovid's spreading cobit
covid
is a subset of symptoms
like aids
aids cannot be spread
hiv is to aids
as sars
cov2 is to coven so if we're trying to
stop anything we should be trying to
stop the spread of the virus sars cov2
which is what a coronavirus
what is a coronavirus
a common cold
it's a common
cold and why is it novel what does novel
mean
novel is something new
whenever a virus mutates it becomes a
novel one so every year every flu virus
is novel every new coronavirus is novel
it's nothing new and it's not novel it's
just
to say it's just the the next the next
uh evolution
of this virus which is completely
natural and the only way we're going to
get hurt immunity is if we let all these
kids and all these healthy adults catch
the thing and then build up their own
natural immunity so like i said there's
a strong chance that i'll be arrested
when i leave here for exercising my
first amendment rights but do you think
i give one f
no i don't
because it's my right to be here and
speak
and i'll pay the forty dollar bail
and i'll get out in maybe an hour or two
it's not a big deal and i will be back
and everybody else that was arrested at
the executive council meeting the other
eight people
do you know a nurse was arrested for
saying amen and then three or four other
people in the room said amen as well at
that executive council meeting but only
nurse therese was arrested
why was that
why were people singled out for
exercising our first amendment which you
obviously don't like very much
do you who are you anyways
guy who are you what's your name so i
can send you an email
sure representative tim lang
representative tim lang thank you sir
so
here i am today exercising my first
amendment rights like i have been
getting arrested for throughout the
entire pandemic peacefully
and there's no threats that have been
made what happened to the
the ag's alleged investigation into
threats made because we know where you
live
why do we know where you live
because it's public record
we the people are to hold you the
government our public servants
accountable to the constitution
that's our job
your job is to abide by the oath that
you took and the story and if you take
away our first amendment rights that's
right the second is going to come out
it's the only one that's going to be
left you're drifting away from policy
we're here to talk about policy medical
intervention
this is about taking away our freedoms
in this state and in this country okay
all of this is connected and if you
can't see it you're blind as a bat you
have one more minute sir i'm done
thank you
is there anybody else who would like to
speak before the
i might have called your name earlier
were you uh
harley no
i'm jim smears i spoke for myself
earlier but i put a card in to speak for
therese
uh you can't you can't speak for
somebody else um i will say that any any
emails that were sent in and theresa did
send an email in was sent to the entire
committee and sent to the record so that
it's included yes so all of all of the
emails that were sent in by anybody that
were forwarded to me i forwarded to the
record so we have it'll be printed out
is there anybody else who would like to
speak laura
hold on
guys
we're going to be we're going to be
well yeah he spoke for himself and his
son just like you said you were speaking
for you and your family right i i
recognize that and allow that to happen
that's a reasonable uh statement so
laura
sure i'll
i'll read the email if anybody if it's
that big of an issue hold on let me go
find it do you want me to just present
it
i i've like i said i've included in the
record give me just one second let me
as you can tell i got a lot of emails on
this topic
um
well it might be faster if you go ahead
and read it because i've got too much
too many emails go ahead and come on if
you want to read teresa's email go ahead
i'll just it'll save me from reading and
no problem
yes thank you and i want to thank each
one of you for providing this forum this
is from me
because even though it is your duty and
for the house it's the
whole
legislature's duty to hear the people
you're the ones who are here listening
so i just
want to clarify that
so this is terese
my name is therese grinnell i'm a
registered nurse for over 10 years
working with critically ill patients
here in concord i appreciate having my
statement read by a fellow patriot as i
have been prohibited from attending
as a result of being charged with a
disorderly conduct
as a result of being accused of saying
amen at a previous public hearing
my questions to this committee are
number one why are we allowing doctors
to be bullied
told they
will be fired via email by concord
hospital if they prescribe ivermectin
even though we now have an nih
government published medical journal
that states ivermectin is 86 effective
in reducing covid19 symptoms
this medical journal has been emailed to
rep laying
number two why are doctors being told
they cannot write a medical exemption
for vaccine mandate for employment for a
person who has already recovered from
covit 19 and lab tests reflect a higher
level of antibodies
[Music]
than a fully vaccinated individual
why should these individuals be forced
to take a warp speed new vaccine with
risk of adverse reactions or lose their
job
scientifically it makes zero sense
number three
how is it possible government overreach
to ensure
the workplace is not violating
civil rights
exemptions are being approved and denied
with no consistent constitutional basis
some employers approving all some
denying all
some approving and denying the same
exact submissions
since we do
oh i'm sorry since when do we allow
discrimination coercion hostility and
harassment in the workplace typically at
the hands of human resource department
and number four we
still do not have the fda approved
vaccine
in stock to administer truth is if we as
employees take vaccine today to keep our
jobs our health insurance policies no
longer cover us
as most policies become null and void if
the deep if the deceased has had
any experimental pharmaceutical
interventions
number five
how is it that right to try is being
denied to families here in new hampshire
a youtube video was sent to me by a
medic medical director at dartmouth and
at 302
three minutes two seconds the
administration speaks to the fact that
only their protocols are to be followed
families requests are to be dismissed
i have emailed that video to rep lang
why would we ever allow this to be okay
what if this was your loved one
in closing the risk of contacting
covid19 in the next 12 months on
historic numbers
is 3 percent with a 99.8
survival rate
that is without proven treatments
that are safe and affordable yet being
denied to the public
this warp speed manufactured injection
is lasting on average six months with a
risk of adverse reactions such as heart
conditions blood clotting neurological
and even death
more now than all other vaccines
combined as documented in vares
it is interesting that most of the
population who was vaccinated early on
or over six months ago should now be
considered unvaccinated yet they were
they are given privileges to work
mandating the vaccine is like telling
someone else to wear a jacket because
you are cold
you can still contract into and transmit
and we have done a horrible job
educating the general public of such
which has also led to hospitalizations
and death
when we realize
there are
several things here that are just not
okay
we have destroyed so many lives by not
treating an initial posit an initial
positive result we have destroyed our
destroying livelihoods communities are
divided schools are a mess hospitals are
insanely short-staffed nursing homes are
hell on earth with frail individuals who
are fully vaccinated having outbreaks
and agency staff filling in with no clue
about the patient
i am an rn a foster mom and have put
everything on the line to do what is
right i beg you to do the same
lives are being lost right here right
now because of horrible health policies
you cannot leave here today and say you
did not know you know
it's time to start saving lives and
saving new hampshire therese grinnell
one of the new hampshire noble nine
arrested on 1013 participating in
the political process
thank you
all right
[Music]
is there anybody else who wish to speak
to the committee
all right
so for the committee i think um what
we'll be doing next is we'll take up
wednesday we'll come in the morning if
there's anybody here that wishes to
testify we'll allow testimony and then
we'll go immediately into a work session
to talk about what a committee report
might look like
and um what the next actions will be
my goal was to wrap it up by friday the
12th if we can get our answers from dhhs
and the medical society that we put
forward to them um
in taking that so does that sound okay
so
again i think that that'll be the
general idea where we're heading we have
to the end of the month but i'd like to
wrap this up as soon as we can
because i know people have holidays
coming up and those kind of things so we
want to make sure we get all the
information we can and then generate our
report from there
so there's nothing else come forward to